Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 16, Build Automation. Take it away, Jason. Hey, so we're working on a crazy hobby project that finally sort of culminated to a terminus. Is that redundant to say crazy hobby project? Yeah, I guess that's true. All my hobby projects are very crazy.
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 16 期，构建自动化。Jason，开始吧。嘿，我们正在做一个疯狂的业余项目，终于算是到了终点。说“疯狂的业余项目”是不是多余了？嗯，我想确实是这样。我所有的业余项目都非常疯狂。
Yeah. Yeah. This one didn't like crash or explode or anything, which is kind of nice. Oh, okay, good. That's a plus. And you finished? Yes yes that's right that's an accomplishment i guess i finished most of it i have a little bit more to do but yeah there's art is never truly finished exactly um but yeah it's called trivipedia and so the idea is you know
是啊。是啊。这个项目没有崩溃或爆炸什么的，这还挺好的。哦，好吧，不错。那是个加分项。你完成了？是的，没错，我想这算是一项成就，我完成了大部分，还有一点点要做，但艺术永远不会真正完成，对吧。嗯，它叫 Trivipedia，所以这个想法是，你知道
i only recently found out that you could download all of wikipedia like the entire text corpus of wikipedia in one zip If you're a glutton for punishment or want to break your bandwidth caps. Yeah, exactly. It's like an 8, 9 gig zip or something. Oh, it's not that bad. And even better, you can download what's called the Squid Logs, and for people who don't know,
我最近才发现你可以下载整个维基百科，也就是维基百科的全部文本语料库，压缩成一个文件。如果你是个自讨苦吃的人，或者想突破带宽限制的话。是的，没错。大概是个 8、9 GB 的压缩包之类的。哦，没那么糟糕。更好的是，你可以下载所谓的 Squid 日志，对于不知道的人来说，
Squid is like a proxy for like, you know, sending messages to different servers and caching and things like that. But long story short is you could download for all of the Wikipedia pages how many hits they received. Like the page you can. Popularity contest.
Squid 就像是一个代理，用于向不同的服务器发送消息、缓存等等。但长话短说，你可以下载所有维基百科页面的点击量。就像你可以看到的页面。人气竞赛。
Yeah, exactly. So I took the most popular Wikipedia pages. What was the most popular page? So the most popular page is Facebook, which is hilarious. Well, this is still recent to the IPO, so... This was, yeah, 2011 data. So I think that, like, maybe people are, like, you know... Because I noticed that Facebook's Wikipedia page is the second search result for Facebook.
是的，没错。所以我选取了最受欢迎的维基百科页面。最受欢迎的页面是什么？最受欢迎的页面是 Facebook，这太搞笑了。嗯，这还是在 IPO 之后不久，所以……这是 2011 年的数据。所以我认为，也许人们是，你知道……因为我注意到 Facebook 的维基百科页面是 Facebook 的第二个搜索结果。
Oh. So, yeah, I think a lot of people are sort of fat-fingering it or something. Maybe. Yeah, and also a lot of uh uh and we're keeping the podcast clean here but you know a lot of uh uh you know certain movie stars were were incredibly popular on wikipedia's they pretty much dominated the top 100 and i was kind of surprised because i know that's how the regular internet is is distributed but I didn't really realize that even on Wikipedia it's the most popular thing. So what is Trivipedia?
哦。所以，是的，我想很多人可能是在乱点或者什么的。也许吧。是的，还有很多……我们在这里保持播客的纯洁性，但你知道，很多……你知道某些电影明星在维基百科上非常受欢迎，他们几乎占据了前 100 名，我有点惊讶，因为我知道普通互联网的分布情况，但我真的没意识到即使在维基百科上，这也是最受欢迎的东西。那么 Trivipedia 是什么？
So yeah, Trivipedia, you can go to www.trivipedia.net. You should probably spell that. Yeah, T-R-I-V-I-P-E-D-I-A.net. And essentially, I curated about 300,000 trivia questions from all this Wikipedia data for the most popular sites. So you'll get a question like, this person is like a young singer, blah, blah, blah, born this year. And your choices might be like Justin Bieber or Justin Timberlake or something, right? And you'd have to click on them.
所以，是的，Trivipedia，你可以访问 www.trivipedia.net。你可能应该拼写一下。是的，T-R-I-V-I-P-E-D-I-A.net。本质上，我从所有这些维基百科数据中为最受欢迎的网站整理了大约 30 万个琐事问题。所以你会得到一个问题，比如，这个人是一位年轻歌手，等等，出生于这一年。你的选项可能是贾斯汀·比伯或贾斯汀·汀布莱克之类的，对吧？你必须点击它们。
I'm going to do terrible at this game. Yeah. There's many different categories. There's like, click on the right name. I'm going to do terrible at this game. Yeah. There's many different categories. There's, like, a SciTech category and stuff. Yay! Yeah, it's pretty fun. There's also an Android app. And I'm just finishing the touches on an iPhone app.
我玩这个游戏肯定很烂。是的。有很多不同的类别。比如，点击正确的名字。我玩这个游戏肯定很烂。是的。有很多不同的类别。有科学技术类等等。耶！是的，这很有趣。还有一个安卓应用。我正在给 iPhone 应用做最后的润色。
Maybe we'll hear more about that later. Yeah, totally. The iPhone app is going to use our tool of the bye week. Oh, teasers. Total spoiler. Teasers, teasers. Coming up. So, yeah, and maybe, you know,
也许我们稍后会听到更多关于它的消息。是的，完全正确。iPhone 应用将使用我们本周的工具。哦，预告。彻底剧透。预告，预告。即将到来。所以，是的，也许，你知道，
if I have $150,000 sitting in my back pocket, I can make a TL top-level domain for Trivopedia. Oh, yeah. So I did want to say that I checked out Trivia. It is pretty cool, and I like that you can kind of be the Trivia crowned champion of your area. Yeah, that's right.
如果我口袋里有 15 万美元，我可以为 Trivopedia 制作一个顶级域名。哦，是的。所以我想说，我查看了 Trivipedia。它非常酷，我喜欢你可以成为你所在地区的琐事冠军。是的，没错。
He uses the location. So, you know, in the beginning, you could be like, you know, Truopedia Knight of Santa Clara County or Knight of Orange County. And as you move your rating up, you can end up being, you know, there's somebody who just...
它使用位置信息。所以，你知道，一开始，你可以是，你知道，圣克拉拉县的 Trivipedia 骑士或奥兰治县的骑士。随着你提升排名，你最终可以成为，你知道，有人刚刚……
I want to be king of like the Bieber questions. I want to like study about Bieber now just to like... No, I won't. That's a lie. that's a lie that's a lie but yeah i think most countries now have a king or queen which means there's at least one oh wow well that's a kind of an accomplishment that's cool to see your work be used around the world yeah yeah the right now the emperor of trivopedia so the person with the highest rating in the world is an american but that's only recently so it used to be a British guy so a little contention there British Emperor should be a king yeah who knows all right so like you were saying so when you earn a hundred and
我想成为比伯问题的国王。我现在想研究比伯，只是为了……不，我不会。那是谎言，那是谎言，那是谎言。但是的，我想大多数国家现在都有国王或王后，这意味着至少有一个。哦，哇，这算是一种成就，看到你的作品在世界各地被使用真是太酷了。是的，是的，现在 Trivipedia 的皇帝，也就是世界上排名最高的人是一个美国人，但这只是最近的事，以前是一个英国人，所以那里有一点争议。英国皇帝应该是国王，是的，谁知道呢。好吧，就像你说的，当你赚到 15
fifty thousand dollars from this yeah I can buy I can buy trivapedia trivapedia my mind exploded so oh yeah so still, we had a few articles talking about all the different top-level domains that were sold or being sold or what were being bid on. I guess they're going to go through an approval process. And so top-level domain is a thing that comes at the end of a URL before the slash is specific to the website. So like.com,.edu,.org. These are the common ones. And then countries have their own, so like.ly or.co. So some of these are more popular than others.
万 5 千美元时，是的，我可以买下 Trivipedia，我的大脑爆炸了。所以，哦，是的，所以仍然有一些文章讨论了所有被出售、正在出售或正在竞标的不同顶级域名。我想它们会经过一个审批程序。所以顶级域名是 URL 末尾斜杠之前的内容，是特定于网站的。比如 .com、.edu、.org。这些是常见的。然后各国都有自己的，比如 .ly 或 .co。所以其中一些比其他的更受欢迎。
But there's a numerable amount. There's not too many. Yeah, and they usually represent something very specific. Like each country has its own, and then there's edu for university. But up until now, it's not like you can just have anything. Right, but now I guess, well, why? Like, why can't we just have anything, you know? And so they're allowing companies to, if they can, there's, like, certain requirements.
但数量很多。不是太多。是的，它们通常代表非常具体的东西。比如每个国家都有自己的，然后有用于大学的 edu。但到目前为止，并不是说你可以随便拥有任何东西。对，但现在我想，嗯，为什么？比如，为什么我们不能随便拥有任何东西，你知道吗？所以他们允许公司，如果他们能，有某些要求。
So it has to be something that's, you know, going to be useful generally. And also, I guess, they have to support, like, other people being able to have, like, subdomains and be essentially their own registrar to allow people to register. Although it wasn't clear to me that they have to allow open registrations or how much they're allowed to charge or what restrictions they can put on it. So a number of companies, Google, Amazon, and others,
所以它必须是，你知道，普遍有用的东西。而且，我想，他们必须支持其他人能够拥有子域名，并本质上成为他们自己的注册商来允许人们注册。虽然我不清楚他们是否必须允许公开注册，或者他们被允许收取多少费用，或者他们可以施加什么限制。所以一些公司，谷歌、亚马逊和其他公司，
this is fairly expensive, like $150,000 to get one of these, but they reserve some kind of crazy ones like LOL or.blog. Of course, Google got google.google, so you could do search.google. I assume things like this, or Amazon, buy.amazon, or shop.amazon. Mobile.amazon.
这相当昂贵，比如 15 万美元才能获得一个，但他们预留了一些疯狂的域名，比如 .LOL 或 .blog。当然，谷歌得到了 google.google，所以你可以做 search.google。我假设类似这样的事情，或者亚马逊，buy.amazon，或 shop.amazon。mobile.amazon。
Yeah, and that's kind of good. It seems like another layer of security. I know I'm going to, if it's something.amazon, I know it's the Amazon page, versus is Amazon.net really Amazon? Like I don't know. But maybe it's also confusing too because now like it's not obvious that if you want to guess a company's thing,
是的，这挺好的。这似乎是另一层安全保障。我知道，如果是 .amazon，我知道它是亚马逊页面，而 amazon.net 真的是亚马逊吗？我不确定。但也许这也令人困惑，因为现在，如果你想猜测一家公司的东西，
you can't just add.com after the end of it. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And, you know, it used to be, you know, with so few choices, each choice used to have sort of intuition behind it. But now that there's going to be just so many choices, like you might have.amazon without the O, like these kind of things might start coming up. Yeah, that's right, make it shorter. Yeah. I don't know, one of those things you hear about
你不能只在末尾加上 .com。是的，是的，完全正确。而且，你知道，过去，选择很少，每个选择背后都有某种直觉。但现在会有这么多选择，比如你可能会有去掉 O 的 .amazon，这类事情可能会开始出现。是的，没错，让它更短。是的。我不知道，你听说过的一件事
when people talk about creativity or art or that kind of thing is that it's those restrictions, the limits, working in bounds, like that makes people very creative. So you end up with these, like people ending i remember delicious was you know what del.icio.us it's like impossible to remember but like it's cool because like they use.us to like spell it delicious or you know like url short notes like bit.ly.oy like these i mean they have ringy names and they're using it's like you get this creativity yeah, if you can have anything,
当人们谈论创造力或艺术或这类事情时，就是那些限制、界限、在范围内工作，这让人们非常有创造力。所以你最终会得到这些，比如人们最终……我记得 delicious 是，你知道 del.icio.us，这简直无法记住，但它很酷，因为他们使用 .us 来拼写 delicious，或者你知道，像 URL 缩短器 bit.ly。这些，我的意思是它们有响亮的名字，而且他们正在使用它，就像你获得了这种创造力。是的，如果你可以拥有任何东西，
I guess there will still be creativity, but it's kind of different because the domain is so much wider open. Yeah, exactly. So some people who missed out on investment and name squatting in the last round of top level domains being open are now saying this is a huge investment opportunity.
我想仍然会有创造力，但这有点不同，因为域名空间要宽广得多。是的，没错。所以一些在上一轮顶级域名开放中错失投资和域名抢注机会的人现在说这是一个巨大的投资机会。
What do you thought? Should you go invest some money? So not buying a top-level domain, but once the domains start opening up, should you go try to register as many as you can on various top levels? So before there was, how many top levels do you think there were before? Maybe 1,000?
你怎么看？你应该去投资一些钱吗？不是购买顶级域名，而是一旦域名开始开放，你应该尝试在各种顶级域名上注册尽可能多的域名吗？所以在此之前，你认为之前有多少个顶级域名？也许 1000 个？
No, I don't think so. Like in the hundreds, yeah. But now, I mean, there's effectively infinite, right? Because as long as you have 150k and you're willing to you know construct a tiny bit of infrastructure you need to give domain subdomains to other people you can have just about anything so i don't know i think that there might be like a land grab in the beginning but i feel like it's once people realize like the gigantic space of names that are possible
不，我不这么认为。大概在几百个左右，是的。但现在，我的意思是，它们实际上是无限的，对吧？因为只要你有 15 万美元，并且你愿意，你知道，构建一点点基础设施，你需要给其他人提供域名子域名，你几乎可以拥有任何东西。所以我不知道，我认为一开始可能会有一场土地争夺战，但我觉得一旦人们意识到可能存在的巨大名称空间，
that uh yeah it's not going to be a very good investment yeah it's hard to say because it's always a strain to say this time is different right like oh there's more so this time will be different than last time well maybe it won't be maybe it won't be like you can't know until afterwards yeah it's true there's some blackmail opportunities like somebody registered i think sucks dot sucks oh so like now every company is going to want to you know have like amazon dot sucks so that they can control it and not you would say bad things about them that's a great but but then with to your point with so many what about like is horrible or yeah you know or vulgarities or right i mean any
那……是的，这不会是一项很好的投资。是的，很难说，因为说“这次不同了”总是很牵强，对吧？就像，哦，有更多了，所以这次会和上次不同。嗯，也许不会，也许不会。就像你直到事后才知道一样。是的，这是真的。有一些勒索机会，比如有人注册了，我想是 sucks.sucks。哦，所以现在每家公司都会想要，你知道，拥有像 amazon.sucks 这样的域名，这样他们就可以控制它，而不是你会说他们的坏话。那太棒了，但随后，针对你的观点，有这么多，那像 is.horrible 或者，你知道，或者粗俗的词，或者对吧？我的意思是任何
sort of like thing after then like why does it have to be, like, if you want a JSON.is awesome, what about JSON.is super or JSON.is fantastic? Like, the land grab seems different to me. Like, you could always find, seems like something that would work. Yeah, you're totally right. I mean, there's so many, like, permutations of just sucks or awesome. Like, there's so many other ways you can say that, right? And they're all available.
那种在后面的东西，为什么它必须是，比如，如果你想要 JSON.is.awesome，那 JSON.is.super 或 JSON.is.fantastic 呢？土地争夺战对我来说似乎不同。比如，你总是可以找到，看起来像是行得通的东西。是的，你是完全正确的。我的意思是，仅仅是 sucks 或 awesome 的排列组合就太多了。我的意思是，还有很多其他方式可以表达这一点，对吧？而且它们都是可用的。
Yeah, so if you were going to create an app, like let's say Trivipedia, and you wanted to have it be freemium, what top-level domain would you choose to ensure a good success? Or do we know anything about that? I think we do know a little bit about the anatomy of freemium from this article, the anatomy of profitable freemium. I thought it was extremely interesting. You know, freemium is sort of the future of a lot of things.
是的，所以如果你要创建一个应用，比如 Trivipedia，并且你想让它采用免费增值模式，你会选择什么顶级域名来确保良好的成功？或者我们对此了解吗？我想我们从这篇文章《盈利性免费增值的解剖》中确实了解了一点关于免费增值解剖学的知识。我觉得它非常有趣。你知道，免费增值是很多事情的未来。
You know, games are becoming more and more freemium. You know, there's some games like, for example, Diablo 3, where although they did charge for the game, there's a marketplace where you can buy and sell items that you've, like, grinded for in the game for real money. And the way it works is blizzard gets a cut of that and so you know if that that's proven to be a huge money maker i think from from articles i've read and so they most likely when diablo 4 comes out they won't even charge for it because they'll just have this marketplace mechanic so a lot of apps are going
你知道，游戏正变得越来越免费增值。你知道，有一些游戏，例如《暗黑破坏神 3》，虽然他们确实对游戏收费，但有一个市场，你可以买卖你在游戏中辛苦刷出来的物品，换取真钱。它的运作方式是暴雪从中抽成，所以你知道，如果这被证明是一个巨大的赚钱工具，我想从我读过的文章来看，所以他们很可能在《暗黑破坏神 4》出来时，甚至不会对它收费，因为他们只会拥有这种市场机制。所以很多应用都将
to the freemium model. It has obvious benefits, right? Because it completely removes the barrier of entry. Like, let's say you think you have no faith in this company. And you know, you don't know if there's going to be a quality game, you have no history, no track record, it has no Metacritic, but it's free, you at least give it a shot, you'd say, let me, you know, make a character and just, you know, even if I got through the character making screen and left, I'd have nothing to lose, right? Yeah, I see what they're saying. So I've played a number of
转向免费增值模式。它有明显的好处，对吧？因为它完全消除了进入门槛。比如，假设你认为你对这家公司没有信心。而且，你知道，你不知道是否会有高质量的游戏，它没有历史，没有记录，没有 Metacritic 评分，但它是免费的，你至少会试一试，你会说，让我，你知道，创建一个角色，然后，你知道，即使我通过了角色创建屏幕然后离开了，我也没什么可损失的，对吧？是的，我明白他们的意思。所以我玩过很多
free-to-play games or whatever, but I have less investment. Like, almost it's more of a waste of time because you, it's a different experience. So you're going game to game. Like, I spend very little time in any one game because I have no commitment to it. I haven't paid anything. So I download it, I play it for an hour or two or a day, and never really get into it it's like oh this control scheme is not amazing or whatever like i never put investment into learning or playing it well and i just skip
免费游戏之类的，但我投入的精力更少。几乎更像是浪费时间，因为你，这是一种不同的体验。所以你从一个游戏跳到另一个游戏。比如，我在任何一个游戏中花费的时间都很少，因为我没有投入。我没有支付任何费用。所以我下载它，玩一两个小时或一天，然后就再也没有真正投入进去。就像，哦，这个控制方案不怎么样，或者什么的，就像我从来没有投入精力去学习或玩好它，我只是跳过
to the next one yeah and just skip to the next one so like i'm still taking up my time but in some ways like i feel like i would be more enjoyable paying for something because then i feel like it's sunk cost and like i need to play it because and then you'll you could be forced into enjoying something that at first seemed not good like you know you read books or watch movies where like if you could leave at any time and there was no kind of barrier to entry of having bought it or rented it or gone to the movie theater like after the first five or ten minutes you might have just walked walked away or flipped the channel or whatever but because you like you stick through it and then it turns out like the movie is really amazing and it's just like you needed to get through those first few minutes to accomplish what the director wanted.
到下一个。是的，只是跳到下一个。所以，我仍然在占用我的时间，但在某些方面，我觉得如果我为某样东西付费，我会更享受，因为那样我觉得这是沉没成本，而且我觉得我需要玩它，因为……然后你可能会被迫去享受一些起初看起来不好的东西，就像，你知道，你读的书或看的电影，如果你可以随时离开，而且没有购买或租借或去电影院的进入门槛，在前五到十分钟后，你可能就走开了，或者换台了，或者什么的，但因为你……你坚持看完，然后结果发现电影真的很棒，就像你只需要熬过最初的那几分钟就能实现导演想要的效果。
Yeah, that's a good point. I mean, if it is freemium, then you really have to impress people from the first few hours of gameplay, I guess. But then doesn't it come down to tricking people? You show all your features up front and you're going to get much more amazing features if you pay but then it turns out like, oh, you're going to get much more amazing features if you pay. But then it turns out like, oh,
是的，那是个好观点。我的意思是，如果是免费增值，那么你真的必须在最初的几个小时的游戏过程中给人们留下深刻印象，我想。但那不是归结为欺骗人们吗？你预先展示了你所有的功能，如果你付费，你会得到更惊人的功能，但结果发现，哦，如果你付费，你会得到更惊人的功能。但结果发现，哦，
actually, this isn't that much more amazing. Yeah, yeah. There is a lot of that. I mean, a lot of these games, like for example, I was playing one called Dungeon Fighter Online. And you pay money to get, I guess, more storage in your backpack.
实际上，这并没有那么惊人。是的，是的。确实有很多这种情况。我的意思是，很多这样的游戏，例如，我正在玩一个叫《地下城与勇士》的游戏。你付钱来获得，我想，背包里更多的存储空间。
But that just made the game more cumbersome because a lot of the things that you hold you don't even need so you could just you're like actually better more agile you're just hoarding stuff yeah yeah it sort of appeals to your hoarding mechanic but at the expense of like actually being better at the game so yeah i mean it's one of these things that you really sort of have to get right and and nobody there's no formula there's no science yet um and so this is one of the few articles as they come across where they actually sort of try to put a science on it and explain like these are some models these are some you know companies have done well with it sometimes
但这只会让游戏变得更麻烦，因为你持有的很多东西你甚至不需要，所以你只是……你实际上更好、更敏捷，你只是在囤积东西。是的，是的，它有点迎合你的囤积机制，但代价是你在游戏中实际上变得更好。所以，是的，我的意思是，这是你真的必须做对的事情之一，而且没有人……没有公式，还没有科学。所以这是我遇到的少数几篇文章之一，他们实际上试图对其进行科学化，并解释说，这些是一些模型，这些是你知道公司有时做得很好，有时
they've done poor one thing that was sort of like a motif across the entire article was that there is a small small subset of the population which they call whales who subsidize the no comment to their actual physical size yeah exactly and these few whales so so let's say you know 900 people or 990 people will play and not pay a dime but then 10 people will pay like a thousand dollars or like hundreds of dollars each and they'll basically subsidize the game for everybody else yeah and that and that's true for games and it's also true for programs like dropbox and evernote and things like that so across the board that's been one common observation i thought that was really interesting that is interesting i
做得不好。文章中贯穿始终的一个主题是，有一小部分人口，他们称之为“鲸鱼”，他们补贴了……不评论他们的实际体型。是的，完全正确。这些少数的鲸鱼……所以，假设你知道，900 人或 990 人会玩而不付一分钱，但 10 个人会支付一千美元或每人几百美元，他们基本上补贴了其他所有人的游戏。是的，这对游戏来说是真的，对 Dropbox 和 Evernote 之类的程序也是真的。所以全面来看，这是一个共同的观察结果，我觉得这真的很有趣。这很有趣，我
mean i think there's a balance. If you like a service, you kind of should pay for it because otherwise you can't complain if it goes away. You weren't paying anything for it. It's annoying. We've all had favorite web services or sites that go away because the author just didn't have time because they weren't making like Trivopedia. If you don't make a lot of money off of that, your incentive to
意思是，我认为有一个平衡。如果你喜欢一项服务，你某种程度上应该为它付费，因为否则如果它消失了，你就不能抱怨。你没有为它支付任何费用。这很烦人。我们都有过最喜欢的网络服务或网站因为作者没有时间而消失，因为他们没有像 Trivipedia 那样赚钱。如果你没有从中赚到很多钱，你维持它的动力
keep it maintained is lower, like no offense. But if it's hugely successful and people are able to contribute money or generate, like you're going to, you know, and people are able to contribute money or generate revenue for you in other ways, you're much more likely to stick with it. I mean, even like, look at the inspiration of Tripopedia. Wikipedia itself is constantly in need of money
就更低，比如，别介意。但如果它非常成功，人们能够贡献金钱或产生，就像你将要做的，你知道，人们能够以其他方式为你产生收入，你更有可能坚持下去。我的意思是，甚至像，看看 Tripopedia 的灵感。维基百科本身一直需要钱，
and they're constantly sort of like on the edge because they have such high bandwidth expenses. Maybe you couldn't monetize it though. It's a fine balance to walk. Yeah, yeah. Freemium is i'm sorry wikipedia is donation where which is has its own set of interesting mechanics and everything i have a feeling that you know when kids grow up they're going to think that was it jimmy wales that he is like everything because because you'll search for say like george washington his personal
而且他们一直处于边缘，因为他们有如此高的带宽费用。也许你无法将其货币化。这是一个很难把握的平衡。是的，是的。免费增值是……我很抱歉，维基百科是捐赠制的，它有自己的一套有趣的机制等等。我有一种感觉，你知道，当孩子们长大后，他们会认为那是 Jimmy Wales，他就是一切，因为因为你会搜索，比如乔治·华盛顿，他的个人
plea and you see like yeah his personal plea is the very first thing. So it's like, I have a wonder if you went to like a five-year-old and he said, who's George Washington? And he had a picture of him and Jimmy Wales. Oh no. It'll be like the McDonald's arch as like most recognizable face.
恳求，你会看到，是的，他的个人恳求是第一件事。所以，我想知道如果你去找一个五岁的孩子，他说，乔治·华盛顿是谁？他有一张他和 Jimmy Wales 的照片。哦，不。它会像麦当劳的拱门一样成为最容易辨认的脸。
Yeah. So if you're trying out all these freemium apps and you've got to generate an account and create a password and you know, what's to say that your password's not going to get leaked like uh our next news story where linkedin yeah linkedin totally busted right so and uh yeah i have like a personal gripe about this because you know i was one of the people whose passwords were leaked i got the email from linkedin when i logged in they told told me to change my password, et cetera. Fortunately, I use a, like, we use KeePass, which is actually something, I think it was a tool of the week. Yeah, so my password, that password was just a throwaway.
是的。所以如果你正在尝试所有这些免费增值应用，你必须生成一个账户并创建一个密码，而且你知道，谁能说你的密码不会像我们的下一个新闻故事那样泄露？LinkedIn，是的，LinkedIn 完全被黑了。所以，而且，是的，我对此有一个个人的抱怨，因为你知道，我是密码被泄露的人之一。我收到了 LinkedIn 的邮件，当我登录时，他们告诉我更改密码，等等。幸运的是，我使用了一个，比如，我们使用 KeePass，这实际上是，我想它是本周的工具。是的，所以我的密码，那个密码只是一个一次性的。
But in the past year, my LinkedIn, my Joystick forum password, and my Twitter password have all been leaked. And, in fact, Twitter twitter they were able to i think we talked about this on our show but someone went into my twitter um and my facebook which they both shared the same key pass password i don't know how that happened but i think i there's some there's a one in a billion chance so you just got lucky pretty sure there was some laziness going on there but uh so that yeah all these passwords got leaked and someone went in and posted as me and it was not pretty. But I had to clean all that up. So, you know, I personally am like, this is really upsetting because I use KeePass.
但在过去的一年里，我的 LinkedIn、我的 Joystick 论坛密码和我的 Twitter 密码都被泄露了。事实上，Twitter，他们能够……我想我们在节目中谈论过这个，但有人进入了我的 Twitter，还有我的 Facebook，它们都共享同一个 KeePass 密码，我不知道那是怎么发生的，但我认为我……有十亿分之一的机会，所以你只是运气好。我很确定那里有一些懒惰，但……所以，是的，所有这些密码都被泄露了，有人进去并以我的名义发帖，那并不好看。但我不得不清理所有这些。所以，你知道，我个人觉得，这真的很令人沮丧，因为我使用 KeePass。
I try and keep everything secure and these passwords are constantly getting leaked out. But at the same time, I can understand them wanting to have an identity. You know, if you use like login with Google or something, then you sort of dilute your brand. You know, like LinkedIn, like Facebook's not going to have a login with Google account and vice versa. So I can see sort of both sides of it. I can see, you know, businesses wanting to have like their own sides of it. I can see businesses wanting to have their own identity of you, but then I can also see how a lot of people aren't taking security seriously.
我尝试保持一切安全，而这些密码却不断地被泄露。但与此同时，我能理解他们想要拥有一个身份。你知道，如果你使用像“用谷歌登录”之类的东西，那么你某种程度上稀释了你的品牌。你知道，比如 LinkedIn，比如 Facebook 不会拥有“用谷歌登录”账户，反之亦然。所以我可以看到它的两面。我可以看到，你知道，企业想要拥有他们自己的身份，但我也可以看到很多人没有认真对待安全问题。
A lot of apps on the iPhone and iPad and stuff, I know more about that than Android, but they seem to offer those and some websites now offer both. Create your own account with that company or use login with facebook or
iPhone 和 iPad 上的很多应用等等，我对那个比对安卓了解更多，但它们似乎提供了这些，现在一些网站也提供了两者。创建你自己的账户，或者使用 Facebook 登录，或者
twitter which i actually like that overflow does that oh okay so i actually feel like that might be the best of both worlds like hey if you're too lazy like do this but if you you know if you want to just create an account because the problem is like some stuff is like only with facebook because they want to spam your board or whatever oh yeah but all your friends yeah it's like that's annoying so like you might want to create your own account. And then also if you don't have Facebook, I don't have a Facebook account. I think I do somewhere, but I don't ever, ever, ever use it. And so I wouldn't even know what the login is for it anymore.
Twitter，我实际上喜欢 Overflow 这样做。哦，好吧。所以我实际上觉得这可能是两全其美的办法，比如，嘿，如果你太懒了，就这样做，但如果你，你知道，如果你想只是创建一个账户，因为问题是，有些东西就像只有 Facebook，因为他们想向你的主页发送垃圾信息或者什么的。哦，是的，但你所有的朋友……是的，这很烦人。所以你可能想创建你自己的账户。而且，如果你没有 Facebook，我没有 Facebook 账户。我想我在某处有一个，但我从来、从来、从来不用它。所以我甚至不知道它的登录名是什么了。
So I would just probably ignore the website. So it's nice when they have an option to create your own and I can just generate something random and use and try it out or whatever. Yeah, yeah, totally, totally. But, yeah, these passwords got leaked. If you use LinkedIn, supposedly they said although the passwords got leaked, no one's account was compromised because they know which passwords were leaked. And so they just locked down those accounts.
所以我可能只会忽略那个网站。所以当他们有一个选项可以创建你自己的账户时，这很好，我可以生成一些随机的东西并使用它，尝试一下，或者什么的。是的，是的，完全正确，完全正确。但是，是的，这些密码被泄露了。如果你使用 LinkedIn，据称他们说虽然密码被泄露了，但没有人被盗号，因为他们知道哪些密码被泄露了。所以他们只是锁定了那些账户。
And so if you got the email I did, the next time you go into LinkedIn, it'll just have you change your password. Oh, that's nice. That's nice. You know, that's something that I think companies are doing a better job. Security is still a big issue. But being upfront, like, hey, something happened to us. And so, like, hey, like, let's just reset everybody or, you know, let's let everybody know.
所以如果你收到了我收到的那封邮件，下次你进入 LinkedIn 时，它会让你更改密码。哦，那很好。那很好。你知道，我认为公司在做这方面做得更好。安全仍然是一个大问题。但坦诚相待，比如，嘿，我们发生了一些事情。所以，比如，嘿，让我们重置每个人，或者，你知道，让每个人都知道。
Like, I feel like they're being much more responsible about that for the most part. I'm sure there's exceptions we don't hear about. Yeah, totally. But, yeah. So if you wanted to, like, learn about security, you know, you might go and try to get, like, a master's degree. But that's pretty expensive. So somebody should do something to, like, offer a master's degree for, like, maybe, like, $100. Man, $100?
就像，我觉得他们在很大程度上对此负责任多了。我相信有一些我们没听说过的例外。是的，完全正确。但是，是的。所以如果你想，比如，学习安全知识，你知道，你可能会去尝试获得，比如，硕士学位。但这相当昂贵。所以有人应该做点什么，比如，提供一个硕士学位，比如，也许，比如，100 美元。伙计，100 美元？
You mean $100,000? No, $100. $100. That's what our next news article talks about. Sebastian Thrun, like, a crazy guy who I keep seeing pop up around the internets. Yeah. He was, like, a Stanford professor. He he's like, he was like a Stanford professor. He's like running his own online college now.
你是说 10 万美元？不，100 美元。100 美元。这就是我们下一篇新闻文章讨论的内容。Sebastian Thrun，像一个疯狂的家伙，我一直看到他在互联网上出现。是的。他曾经是，比如，斯坦福大学的教授。他……他曾经是斯坦福大学的教授。他现在在经营自己的在线大学。
And like, he also, I think he even works at Google. Like, I don't know how one person has enough time to do all of those things. But he, in an interview was talking about that, you know, he wants to revolutionize online education, which I agree. I was talking to somebody about saving. So I have a young child, you know, my daughter's, you you know be many years before she goes to college and so one thing you think about is like should i start saving for you know college because although it's many years away the earlier you start the easier it is um but i don't even know like i do and i probably will
而且，我想他甚至在谷歌工作。比如，我不知道一个人怎么有足够的时间做所有这些事情。但他，在一次采访中谈到，你知道，他想彻底改变在线教育，我同意。我正在和某人谈论储蓄。所以我有一个年幼的孩子，你知道，我女儿，你知道，离她上大学还有很多年，所以你想到的一件事是，比如，我应该开始为，你知道，大学存钱吗？因为虽然离现在还有很多年，但你开始得越早，就越容易。嗯，但我甚至不知道，比如，我确实，而且我可能会
but i don't know that education will be the same for my daughter that that we went through yeah i think that you know the you know as we move to online and things like that the number of students that a teacher can teach grows dramatically and i think the bubble on education might burst you know well not just like the ability for a teacher to teach so many more people but the best teachers can teach the people i mean i had a lot of i went to a great college, I had a lot of teachers. I went to a great college, but I had a lot of teachers who, you know. And so if you could get the best teacher, and then this sounds really bad, but, you know, just like other people, right, like those teachers or whatever become kind of teaching assistants.
但我不知道教育对我女儿来说会和我经历的一样。是的，我认为，你知道，随着我们转向在线教育之类的事情，老师能教的学生数量会急剧增加，我认为教育泡沫可能会破裂。你知道，嗯，不仅仅是老师能教更多人的能力，而是最好的老师能教人们。我的意思是，我有很多……我上了一所很棒的大学，我有很多老师。我上了一所很棒的大学，但我有很多老师，你知道。所以如果你能得到最好的老师，然后这听起来真的很糟糕，但，你知道，就像其他人一样，对吧，那些老师或者什么的变成了某种助教。
So because there are so many students, they have the same size class, but somebody else is doing the lecturing, and they're really there one-on-one helping people, going through the concepts in fine detail. Like I think in general that could probably be a better model yeah totally so sebastian is trying to he's currently he ran a cs 101 where you built your own search engine which oh i actually kind of wanted to do like just to do it and then he did introduction to ai which of course stanford also had one but he did one which was uh learning to drive or learning to program self-driving car no nice so I don't know if that comes from his Google work or not are these classes that anyone can just go to and yeah so I don't think there's any cost so it's completely free
所以因为学生太多，他们有同样大小的班级，但其他人正在讲课，而他们真正是在一对一地帮助人们，详细地讲解概念。我觉得总的来说，这可能是一个更好的模型。是的，完全正确。所以 Sebastian 正在尝试……他目前经营了一门 CS 101，你可以在那里构建你自己的搜索引擎，哦，我实际上有点想做，只是为了做它。然后他做了人工智能导论，当然斯坦福大学也有一门，但他做了一门，是关于……学习驾驶或学习编程自动驾驶汽车。不，不错。所以我不知道这是否来自他在谷歌的工作，还是这些是任何人都可以去的课程？是的，所以我认为没有任何成本，所以它是完全免费的。
you go you take the class they have tests they have homework late that's a pretty big commitment I've done a couple I've never successfully finished them because I just can't bring myself to do homework and I haven't paid anything. You have like three virtual Fs. No, I have way more than three virtual Fs. It's horrible. But yeah, so anyone can register. I mean, it lists like what are good prerequisites. So like if you're going to do CS, like it's certain math and statistics you probably need to be able to be successful. You can probably pick it up if you're really dedicated to it. And you could totally go at your own pace. So let's say you take the class and it turns out, oh, I don't have what it takes to take this class.
你去上课，他们有考试，他们有家庭作业。那是一个相当大的承诺。我做过几个，我从来没有成功完成过，因为我就是无法强迫自己做作业，而且我没有支付任何费用。你有三个虚拟的 F。不，我有远不止三个虚拟的 F。这太可怕了。但是的，所以任何人都可以注册。我的意思是，它列出了什么是好的先决条件。所以如果你要学习 CS，比如，某些数学和统计学你可能需要才能成功。如果你真的致力于此，你可能可以学会。而且你可以完全按照自己的节奏进行。所以假设你上这门课，结果发现，哦，我没有能力上这门课。
You could take another class. Like you could take algebra from iTunes U. There's 100 universities that have that online. And then go back with your new knowledge. Yeah, try again and try again. So he's trying to do a world record setting. I forget how many. I believe it's in the hundreds of thousands.
你可以上另一门课。比如你可以从 iTunes U 上学习代数。有 100 所大学在线提供这些课程。然后带着你的新知识回来。是的，再试一次，再试一次。所以他正在尝试创造一项世界纪录。我忘记了多少。我相信是几十万。
I don't have the article up in front of me but hundreds of thousands of people he needs and he's going to do an introduction to statistics course and he wants to set the record for most people in an online course um and so this is this is pretty good i encourage you if you're interested in statistics statistics is something that i think in modern society that everybody has to have you hear statistics thrown at you constantly to be able to do expected value, to be able to do these kinds of things. You don't need to be able to do Bayesian inference or crazy complex, all that stuff's really cool
我面前没有这篇文章，但几十万他需要的人，他将开设一门统计学导论课程，他想为在线课程中人数最多的人数设定纪录。嗯，所以这……这相当不错，如果你对统计学感兴趣，我鼓励你。统计学是我认为在现代社会中每个人都必须具备的东西。你不断听到统计数据向你抛来，为了能够进行期望值计算，为了能够做这些事情。你不需要能够进行贝叶斯推理或疯狂的复杂计算，所有这些东西真的很酷
and very useful. But as a person in a modern high-tech society, the amount of things that if you knew statistics would help you clarify or think through or attempt to make rational decisions is very important. It's very important to know statistics. Yeah.
而且非常有用。但作为一个现代高科技社会的人，如果你懂统计学，能帮助你澄清或思考或尝试做出理性决策的事情的数量是非常重要的。了解统计学非常重要。是的。
I mean, even just like basic causal analysis, you know, like, you know, everyone's heard the cliche, if you flip a penny three times and you get heads all three times, what's the chance you're going to get heads the fourth time? Of course, it's 50-50 because, you know those there's no interdependencies just because you got heads the first three times doesn't mean anything about the fourth flip right and there's a lot more than just that simple rule in statistics which will really sort of give you good intuitions to make smart decisions and then the subtlety to that right like if you flip ahead four times in a row that fourth time is ahead now like you know next in flips, it will revert to the mean.
我的意思是，甚至只是像基本的因果分析，你知道，你知道，每个人都听过那个陈词滥调，如果你抛一枚硬币三次，三次都是正面，第四次得到正面的几率是多少？当然是 50-50，因为，你知道，没有相互依赖性，仅仅因为你前三次得到正面并不意味着第四次抛掷有什么意义，对吧？统计学中不仅仅有那个简单的规则，它真的会给你很好的直觉来做出明智的决定。还有其中的微妙之处，对吧？如果你连续抛出四个正面，那第四次现在是正面……接下来在抛掷中，它会回归平均值。
So chances are you will have less tails than head, but still any one flip is the same. So it's all this crazy stuff. Or one always gets me, which I like, and they're kind of enjoyable logic puzzles, is if somebody has two kids and you know that one of them is a boy, what's the chance that the other one is a girl? If somebody has two kids and you know that one of them is a boy what's the chance that the other one is a girl somebody has two kids and you know one of them is a boy what's the chance that the other is a girl i feel like i'm walking you know yeah yeah but i'm pretty sure it's 50 50 right uh so it actually turns out it's not as it gets confusing so let me see if i can do this correct
所以很有可能你会得到比正面少的反面，但仍然任何一次抛掷都是一样的。所以这都是这些疯狂的事情。或者一个总是让我困惑的，我喜欢，而且它们是相当有趣的逻辑谜题，是如果某人有两个孩子，你知道其中一个是男孩，另一个是女孩的几率是多少？如果某人有两个孩子，你知道其中一个是男孩，另一个是女孩的几率是多少？某人有两个孩子，你知道其中一个是男孩，另一个是女孩的几率是多少？我觉得我在走……你知道，是的，是的，但我很确定是 50-50，对吧？嗯，实际上结果不是，因为它变得令人困惑。所以让我看看我能不能做对。
maybe i'll be wrong uh so i believe that so the reason why is because either one can be a boy. So the chance of the other one being a boy means that both have to be boys, which is a one in four chance. So the chance of another one being a girl is the other of that. So it's a 75% chance that the other one is a girl. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. So it's because I didn't tell you the first one is a boy. Yeah, yeah.
也许我会错。嗯，所以我相信，所以原因是因为任何一个都可以是男孩。所以另一个是男孩的几率意味着两个都必须是男孩，这是四分之一的几率。所以另一个是女孩的几率是剩下的。所以另一个是女孩的几率是 75%。是的，是的，这说得通。所以是因为我没有告诉你第一个是男孩。是的，是的。
What's the second one? Either of them is a boy. So I told you only one, and I didn't tell you the first one is a boy. Yeah, yeah. What's the second one? Either of them is a boy. So I told you only one, and I didn't tell you the position. Nice. I think that's right. Somebody's going to email us and tell us I'm wrong. That sounds totally legit. So, okay, anyways.
第二个是什么？其中任何一个是男孩。所以我只告诉你一个，我没有告诉你第一个是男孩。是的，是的。第二个是什么？其中任何一个是男孩。所以我只告诉你一个，我没有告诉你位置。不错。我想那是对的。有人会发邮件告诉我们我错了。这听起来完全合法。所以，好吧，无论如何。
If you want to trick your friends, there's a lot of puzzles. And maybe you could read about those statistics courses on your new Microsoft Surface tablet. Yeah, yeah. Maybe there's an app for that. Oh, wait. You're giving away what our thoughts are about it. Yeah, at this point, that's a double spoiler.
如果你想戏弄你的朋友，有很多谜题。也许你可以在你的新 Microsoft Surface 平板电脑上阅读那些统计学课程。是的，是的。也许有一个应用程序可以做到这一点。哦，等等。你正在泄露我们对此的想法。是的，在这一点上，那是双重剧透。
But, yeah, basically the Microsoft Surface tablet was announced. And I think you know more about this than me. Oh, well, I got trapped into one of my friends is like, oh, are you going to watch it? I'm like, oh, okay, all right. I guess I'll watch the live announcement. And this is, I think it was earlier this last week, we got messed up technical difficulties,
但是，是的，基本上 Microsoft Surface 平板电脑发布了。而且我想你比我更了解这个。哦，好吧，我被困住了，我的一个朋友说，哦，你要看吗？我说，哦，好吧，好吧。我想我会看现场发布会。这是，我想是上周早些时候，我们搞砸了，技术故障，
so we're redoing some of these news stories. We're never particularly on top of the ball as far as getting our news stories very timely. But that's okay because we like to talk about the broader concepts. And you can find all of the links online in our show notes. But Microsoft had this live announcement, like we're going to talk about this stuff. And you can find all of the links online in our show notes. But Microsoft had this live announcement, like, we're going to talk about this stuff. And then as soon as I saw what it was, I was like,
所以我们正在重做其中一些新闻故事。我们在及时获取新闻故事方面从来都不是特别领先。但这没关系，因为我们喜欢谈论更广泛的概念。你可以在我们的节目笔记中找到所有在线链接。但微软有这个现场发布会，就像我们要谈论这些东西一样。你可以在我们的节目笔记中找到所有在线链接。但微软有这个现场发布会，就像我们要谈论这些东西一样。然后当我看到它是什么时，我就想，
oh, fail. It's like, we've made something that's, like, more than a tablet. It's got this keyboard and a kickstand. And those are all really amazing things. But, you know, part of the allure of a tablet in my use is, like, it's simplicity. You do one thing at a time. It's very simple. If I want to do anything more, I'm going to get on my computer yeah but i want my tablet to be simple and awesome
哦，失败。就像，我们制造了一些东西，比如，不仅仅是一个平板电脑。它有这个键盘和支架。这些都是非常了不起的事情。但是，你知道，平板电脑在我使用中的魅力的一部分是，比如，它的简单性。你一次做一件事。它非常简单。如果我想做任何更多的事情，我会用我的电脑。是的，但我想要我的平板电脑简单而棒。
and really good at what it does and you know be easy to use and i can use it late at night when i don't want to have to do thousand things and it has good battery life and every time you try to make it do something a little bit more you're you're sacrificing something else you know either cost battery life like something you can't get them all and then the fact that you know, either cost, battery life, like something, you can't get them all. And then the fact that, you know, they're going to have like a lower end tablet, which the pricing's not quite out yet. And then a higher end tablet is going to be essentially a laptop. And it's just like, they're going to have a full processor. I'm like, how hot is this thing going to get? What's the battery life going to be? You know? And then, yeah, it's amazing. They showed it running Lightroom, which is a photo editing app. It'd be amazing to be able to run Lightroom
而且它非常擅长它所做的事情，你知道，它易于使用，我可以在深夜不想做成千上万件事的时候使用它，而且它的电池续航能力很好，每次你试图让它多做一点事情时，你都在牺牲其他东西，你知道，要么是成本，要么是电池续航，就像有些东西你无法面面俱到，而且事实上，你知道，他们会推出一款低端平板电脑，价格还没完全出来。然后高端平板电脑基本上就是一台笔记本电脑。它就像是，他们会配备一个完整的处理器。我在想，这东西会变得多热？电池续航会怎样？你知道吗？然后，是的，这太棒了。他们展示了它运行 Lightroom，这是一款照片编辑应用程序。能够在我的平板电脑上运行 Lightroom 将会非常棒
on my tablet. But you know, if it's going to have to running Lightroom, which is a photo editing app. It'd be amazing to be able to run Lightroom on my tablet. But if it's going to have to do all these other things and the battery life is going to be horrible and it's going to be very expensive. Yeah, I mean, wasn't the claim that it could run any Windows app or something like that? I think that was one of the claims of the more advanced ones, like the Pro model or whatever. But I don't want my...
在我的平板电脑上。但你知道，如果它必须运行 Lightroom，那是一款照片编辑应用程序。能够在我的平板电脑上运行 Lightroom 将会非常棒。但如果它必须做所有这些其他事情，电池续航会很糟糕，而且它会非常昂贵。是的，我的意思是，声称它可以运行任何 Windows 应用程序之类的说法不是真的吗？我认为这是更高级型号（比如 Pro 型号或其他什么）的卖点之一。但我不想让我的……
So it's going to open Pandora's box, right? Yes. I mean... Because now they have to support all sorts of quirks from previous Windows versions and crazy things. I noticed even switching between my phone and I have a Motorola Zoom tablet, the compatibility varies wildly. An app that will work fine on the phone will just completely bomb on the tablet. And it's not just the obvious things like the screen display being shifted, although that happens a lot.
所以这会打开潘多拉魔盒，对吧？是的。我的意思是……因为现在他们必须支持以前 Windows 版本中的各种怪癖和疯狂的事情。我注意到即使是在我的手机和摩托罗拉 Zoom 平板电脑之间切换，兼容性也大不相同。一个在手机上运行良好的应用程序在平板电脑上会完全崩溃。这不仅仅是屏幕显示偏移这种显而易见的事情，尽管这种情况经常发生。
A lot of apps, you go to touch and there's some weird shifting going on because they weren't expecting the screen size of the tablet. But even just more subtle things, like certain processes will just crash. Like there's this thing called Open Faint, which is a way to save your score in the cloud. Like a high scoreboard thing. Yeah, yeah.
很多应用程序，你去触摸时会出现一些奇怪的偏移，因为它们没有预料到平板电脑的屏幕尺寸。但即使是更微妙的事情，比如某些进程也会直接崩溃。比如有一个叫 Open Faint 的东西，这是一种在云端保存分数的方法。就像一个高分排行榜之类的东西。是的，是的。
So any game that had that would crash on my system. Oh. Yeah, yeah. So it has nothing to do, really, with the display or anything. Yeah, so the iPhone 1's not as bad. The iOS does. It's pretty good. I haven't had a lot of issues with that. Yeah, my phone's good about that.
所以任何带有那个功能的游戏都会在我的系统上崩溃。哦。是的，是的。所以这真的与显示器或其他任何东西无关。是的，所以 iPhone 1 没那么糟糕。iOS 系统做得很好。我在这方面没遇到太多问题。是的，我的手机在这方面表现不错。
But yeah, I mean, just the Windows thing. Like, I mean, oh, it'd be so cool. I could run Quick 2 on my tablet. Yeah, I'm sure that'll be there. But it's like, oh, but what is the experience going to be like? In reality, although it's cool to do that, people need to have the tablet experience in mind. You want somebody to sit down and design it. The more you try to make it do and the less custom tailored it is, the less enjoyable it is to some extent.
但是的，我的意思是，关于 Windows 的事情。我的意思是，哦，那太酷了。我可以在我的平板电脑上运行 Quake 2。是的，我相信那会有的。但就像，哦，但体验会是什么样的呢？实际上，虽然这样做很酷，但人们需要考虑到平板电脑的体验。你希望有人坐下来设计它。你越是试图让它做更多的事情，它就越不量身定制，在某种程度上，它就越不令人愉快。
Yeah, totally. You know what would be awesome is if they had it run the iOS simulator. Oh. And you could download iOS apps. Yeah, awesome. That's a word for it. But another cool thing, they have the cover that has a keyboard on it. That is cool.
是的，完全同意。你知道什么会很棒吗？如果他们让它运行 iOS 模拟器。哦。然后你可以下载 iOS 应用程序。是的，太棒了。这是一个很好的词。但另一件很酷的事情是，他们有带键盘的保护套。那真的很酷。
And I thought that's pretty cool. But, you know, I mean, anybody could do it. It's not like Amazing Leap Forward. I feel like it's a me too me too you know and then it has a kickstand on the back you could flip out the little stand and it stands up no one's done that before like i much prefer having it without this stand be a little thinner and then i'll just get a ten dollar aftermarket stand that is exactly the stand i want for my use case you know yeah so um but this one comes in hot pink.
我觉得那很酷。但是，你知道，我的意思是，任何人都能做到。这不像是一个惊人的飞跃。我觉得这是一种“我也是，我也是”的感觉，你知道，然后它背面有一个支架，你可以翻出那个小支架，它就能立起来，以前没人做过那样的事，我更喜欢没有这个支架，让它薄一点，然后我会买一个十美元的售后支架，那正是我在我的使用场景下想要的支架，你知道，是的，所以嗯，但这一个有亮粉色。
Whoa! No, no, no, no, no. You didn't tell me. Hot pink? I'm totally buying one now. Oh, man. Gotta get it. Okay. Well, anyways.
哇！不，不，不，不，不。你没告诉我。亮粉色？我现在一定要买一个。哦，天哪。一定要买。好吧。嗯，总之。
I think it's time for our... I don't have a good transition. I was doing so good, but... Tool of the Buy Week. That's right. We made up for it by both saying that at the same time. It's awesome. So, my Tool of the Buy Week is Apache Cordova, week that's right we made up for it by both saying that at the same time it's awesome so um my tool
我想是时候进行我们的……我没有一个好的过渡。我刚才做得很好，但是……本周购买工具。没错。我们同时说出来，弥补了这一点。太棒了。所以，我的本周购买工具是 Apache Cordova，没错，我们同时说出来，弥补了这一点，太棒了，所以嗯，我的工具
the buy week is um apache cordova which used to be called phone gap and this thing is pretty awesome basically the way it works is you know right now if you want to make an app for the phone as i as i did with trivopedia you know you either have to write a separate app for every type of phone. So in other words, you have to bust out your Java skills and write the Android app in Java. Then you have to go to the iPhone and write an Objective-C app. And then you have to go to the Windows Mobile. And I don't even know what that is.
本周购买工具是嗯 Apache Cordova，它以前被称为 PhoneGap，这个东西非常棒，基本上它的工作方式是，你知道现在如果你想为手机制作一个应用程序，就像我用 Trivipedia 做的那样，你知道你要么必须为每种类型的手机编写一个单独的应用程序。换句话说，你必须拿出你的 Java 技能，用 Java 编写 Android 应用程序。然后你必须去 iPhone 那里编写一个 Objective-C 应用程序。然后你必须去 Windows Mobile 那里。我甚至不知道那是什么。
That sounds like fun. Yeah, that's painful, right? Incredibly painful. So fortunately, all of the phones support JavaScript. So actually, you can write JavaScript code for the iPhone. And for Android, I think it pops up like a web view and launches your JavaScript. But it feels like a natural app. So you can actually, if you did it right, you can write your code in JavaScript
听起来很有趣。是的，那很痛苦，对吧？极其痛苦。所以幸运的是，所有的手机都支持 JavaScript。所以实际上，你可以为 iPhone 编写 JavaScript 代码。对于 Android，我想它会弹出一个类似 web view 的东西并启动你的 JavaScript。但它感觉就像一个原生应用程序。所以你实际上，如果你做得对，你可以用 JavaScript 编写你的代码
and it would work across all these devices, assuming you had kind of the right middleware layer. And that's what PhoneGap is. So PhoneGap, you write HTML and JavaScript as if you're making a website. And then what PhoneGap does is it converts your website buttons and your website pull-down menus and stuff into the native controls. So if you were to, say, click a link in a website and it takes you to a new page and then you have the browser bar at the top,
并且它可以在所有这些设备上运行，假设你有一种正确的中间件层。这就是 PhoneGap。所以 PhoneGap，你编写 HTML 和 JavaScript，就像你在制作一个网站一样。然后 PhoneGap 所做的是将你的网站按钮、网站下拉菜单之类的东西转换为原生控件。所以如果你，比如说，点击网站上的一个链接，它带你到一个新页面，然后你在顶部有浏览器栏，
that's not really the experience you want when you're making a native phone app, right? No. This sort of obfuscates all of that. So it gets rid of the browser bar. It makes the URLs go to like, not really go to real pages, but they sort of compact all the pages into the application. So it feels very smooth and quick.
当你制作原生手机应用程序时，那并不是你想要的体验，对吧？不。这在某种程度上掩盖了所有这些。所以它去掉了浏览器栏。它使 URL 看起来像，不是真的去真正的页面，但它们将所有页面压缩到应用程序中。所以它感觉非常流畅和快速。
There's no loading screens or anything. Yeah, yeah. So it's like it's storing locally all the pages. Yeah, exactly. It sort of like does this compilation process. And it's great. You know, I had it. I tested it on, you know, I made the Android app for Trivapg already.
没有加载屏幕之类的东西。是的，是的。所以它就像是在本地存储所有页面。是的，完全正确。它有点像执行这个编译过程。这很棒。你知道，我有过。我在，你知道，我已经为 Trivipedia 制作了 Android 应用程序。
So I didn't need to use PhoneGap for that. But I did anyways. I built an Android version, and it ran pretty well. Oh, cool. Yeah, and I mainly used it for the iPhone version and it went really well. So pretty happy with the performance. So are we going to see you on the App Store soon? I hope so, yeah.
所以我不需要为此使用 PhoneGap。但我还是用了。我构建了一个 Android 版本，它运行得相当好。哦，酷。是的，我主要把它用于 iPhone 版本，它运行得非常好。所以对性能非常满意。那么我们很快会在 App Store 上看到你吗？我希望如此，是的。
I'm actually on the Android App Store already with the native Android app. I should be on the iPhone App Store pretty soon. I have to save up for that $100 developer's fee that they want to smack me with. It's like getting hit with a 40-pound trout. Bam! That's a large trout, 40 pounds. That's a big trout. Getting a trout to the face is not fun.
我实际上已经在 Android App Store 上有了原生的 Android 应用程序。我应该很快就会在 iPhone App Store 上架。我必须存钱支付他们想向我收取的 100 美元开发者费用。这就像被一条 40 磅重的鳟鱼击中一样。砰！那是一条大鳟鱼，40 磅。那是一条大鳟鱼。被鳟鱼打脸可不好玩。
That sounds pretty cool. So can you also run it on the website? If you did it from the beginning, could you have it be your main website as well? Or would that be awkward? Yeah, you can't do that. But I actually started from the web version.
听起来很酷。那么你也可以在网站上运行它吗？如果你从一开始就这样做，你能让它也成为你的主网站吗？还是会很尴尬？是的，你不能那样做。但我实际上是从网页版本开始的。
The very first version was just the website that I copied and pasted into PhoneGap. And that actually worked. It was clunky because it was meant for a desktop. So you can't actually do PhoneGap for PC. But you can take your website and port it over and it
最初的版本只是我复制并粘贴到 PhoneGap 中的网站。那实际上奏效了。它很笨重，因为它是为桌面设计的。所以你不能真的为 PC 使用 PhoneGap。但你可以把你的网站移植过来，它
is close to the same. So it gets two thumbs up for you. Two thumbs way up. And that's free. PhoneGap's totally free open source. And supposedly it'll even work on like Windows, Microsoft Surface tablet. Which you are totally buying in Hot Pink. With all the money you make from Trivipedia.
几乎是一样的。所以它为你赢得了两个赞。两个大拇指向上。而且它是免费的。PhoneGap 完全是免费开源的。而且据说明它甚至可以在像 Windows、Microsoft Surface 平板电脑上运行。你完全会买亮粉色的那个。用你从 Trivipedia 赚的所有钱。
Yeah, if enough people buy Trivipedia, I will get a hot pink Surface tablet. Yay! That'll be our cover art forever. Yeah, exactly. If that happens. Maybe we'll just go to the Microsoft store and take a picture of you with it, and then it'll be our cover art. No, yeah, it'd be awesome. I think I'll do it. I'll have two. Like, you know how you see those
是的，如果足够多的人购买 Trivipedia，我会买一个亮粉色的 Surface 平板电脑。耶！那将永远是我们的封面艺术。是的，完全正确。如果那发生了。也许我们只会去微软商店拍一张你拿着它的照片，然后它就会成为我们的封面艺术。不，是的，那会很棒。我想我会做的。我会买两个。就像，你知道你怎么看那些
car commercials? People with two guns? Oh, no. No, where it's like a guy and he's got two Budweiser babes or whatever. Yeah, I'll have the two pot pink Surface tablets. Okay, we won't tell your wife about this. I don't know if she listens to this show or not, but my tool of the buy week is Xbox Media Center, which is actually not called that anymore. Oh, really?
汽车广告吗？拿着两把枪的人？哦，不。不，就像一个家伙，他有两个百威宝贝之类的。是的，我会买两个亮粉色的 Surface 平板电脑。好吧，我们不会告诉你妻子这件事。我不知道她是否听这个节目，但我的本周购买工具是 Xbox Media Center，它实际上不再叫那个名字了。哦，真的吗？
Just XBMC because it's not just for the Xbox anymore. So this was a project that, if I recall correctly, originally started out on the original Xbox, which is a PC, just without full windows on it. And so they re-scripted it. It had a program that would run, and you would have to hack it,
只是 XBMC，因为它不再仅仅是为 Xbox 设计的。所以这是一个项目，如果我没记错的话，最初是在原始 Xbox 上开始的，它是一台 PC，只是没有完整的 Windows 系统。所以他们重新编写了它。它有一个可以运行的程序，你必须破解它，
and you could put this on there, and it made it into, what it says, a media center. So you could play DVDs like a DVD player. You could add a hard drive in the Xbox. You could put stuff on your hard drive and you could play MP3s and movies that way. Just a really flexible thing. And over time, it's just continued to support other
然后你可以把它放在上面，它就变成了一个，正如它所说的，媒体中心。所以你可以像 DVD 播放器一样播放 DVD。你可以在 Xbox 中添加一个硬盘驱动器。你可以把东西放在你的硬盘驱动器上，你可以通过这种方式播放 MP3 和电影。只是一个非常灵活的东西。随着时间的推移，它继续支持其他
platforms. And they did a really good job that some open source projects managed to do just amazingly well, which is kind of make a completely modular platform. So they're able to just have this back end to run on the Xbox, but this whole front end, like UI and media manager and rating
平台。他们做得非常好，一些开源项目设法做得非常出色，那就是制造一个完全模块化的平台。所以他们能够让这个后端在 Xbox 上运行，但整个前端，比如 UI 和媒体管理器以及评分
system and all this stuff that could be platform independent, it does allow them to kind of support even more than the original Xbox. Now I think it even runs on the Xbox 360, I'm not sure, but it'll run on your PC, so you can just run it as what they call a 10-foot interface. So something that you can use from your couch with a remote if you have it hooked up to your computer.
系统和所有这些东西都可以是平台无关的，它确实允许他们支持比原始 Xbox 更多的东西。现在我想它甚至可以在 Xbox 360 上运行，我不确定，但它可以在你的 PC 上运行，所以你可以把它作为他们所谓的 10 英尺界面运行。所以如果你把它连接到你的电脑上，你可以用遥控器在沙发上使用它。
I think it supports OSX, Linux, Windows. Also, I think they have a version to run on the Apple TV, so if you jailbreak your Apple TV, you can run it there. Or you have to jailbreak. Yeah, you do have to jailbreak because Apple doesn't actually let you run any apps. It's like a download apps on your Apple TV. I don't have an Apple TV, but I believe that's correct. As you can jailbreak it, you can run your own apps, and then this is one of the apps,
我想它支持 OSX、Linux、Windows。另外，我想他们有一个可以在 Apple TV 上运行的版本，所以如果你越狱你的 Apple TV，你就可以在那里运行它。或者你必须越狱。是的，你必须越狱，因为 Apple 实际上不允许你运行任何应用程序。就像在你的 Apple TV 上下载应用程序一样。我没有 Apple TV，但我相信那是正确的。只要你能越狱，你就可以运行你自己的应用程序，然后这是其中一个应用程序，
or maybe it's like an actual boot to it as an operating system. Wow, you can even do it on the iPad. That's impressive. Oh, that's cool. So that's probably like actually two, maybe like the same front-end interface thing, right? So what happens is you can just set up on a NAS, a network-attached storage,
或者也许它就像一个实际引导到它的操作系统。哇，你甚至可以在 iPad 上做。这令人印象深刻。哦，那很酷。所以那可能就像实际上两个，也许就像同一个前端界面东西，对吧？所以发生的事情是你可以只在 NAS（网络附加存储）上设置，
or just like a PC running or even just internet and just have kind of that as your back-end, a source for media and data or whatever, and stream it to this XBMC client and just run stuff, play stuff. And it's cool because some of these devices are crippled, so you get an Apple TV and it's like, I wish I could do a little bit more. Well, Apple TVs are pretty cheap. I think they're like a hundred dollars so i mean way easier to maintain and take care of it and still do what you want by installing this on there than running like a
或者只是像一台运行中的 PC，甚至只是互联网，然后把那个作为你的后端，作为媒体和数据等的来源，并将其流式传输到这个 XBMC 客户端并运行东西，播放东西。这很酷，因为其中一些设备被阉割了，所以你买了一个 Apple TV，你会想，我希望我能多做一点。嗯，Apple TV 很便宜。我想它们大约一百美元，所以我的意思是比运行像
whole other pc and paying for extra power and and all of that um so that's kind of cool or space you know pc takes a lot yeah and apple tv is very small or even like xbox 360 or an xbox you can buy them very very cheap so if you have an entertainment center and you can put one of these in there, and for, you know, what does the Xbox sell for these days? Probably like $50 for a used one. You don't even care if it's probably got a broken optical drive if, you know, assuming there's another way to install the Xbox.
另一台 PC 并支付额外电力和所有这些费用更容易维护和照顾，并且仍然通过在上面安装这个来做你想做的事情，嗯，所以这很酷，或者空间，你知道 PC 占用很多空间，是的，Apple TV 非常小，甚至像 Xbox 360 或 Xbox，你可以非常非常便宜地买到它们，所以如果你有一个娱乐中心，你可以把其中一个放在那里，而且，你知道，Xbox 这些天卖多少钱？可能像 50 美元一个二手的。你甚至不在乎它是否可能有一个坏掉的光驱，如果，你知道，假设有另一种安装 Xbox 的方法。
You just need it to do one thing, right? So like you can get it really cheap. And then, you know, whatever the back end you have for your house, you can have all these different front ends. And it's just a really nifty thing, so check it out. That's totally awesome. Also, I use it as even just on my Windows PC at home, instead of Windows Media Center,
你只需要它做一件事，对吧？所以你可以买到非常便宜的。然后，你知道，无论你家里有什么后端，你都可以拥有所有这些不同的前端。这真是一个非常灵巧的东西，所以去看看吧。这太棒了。另外，我甚至在家里把它用在我的 Windows PC 上，而不是 Windows Media Center，
because I have a TV tuner card. This doesn't support TV tuner, at least not that I saw. I didn't really try that hard. But for just general like watching movies or whatever, the Media Center on Windows is terrible, so this is much better. Yeah.
因为我有一张电视调谐卡。这个不支持电视调谐器，至少我没看到。我没有真正尝试过。但对于一般的看电影之类的，Windows 上的 Media Center 很糟糕，所以这个好多了。是的。
So I like this a lot. So I use it to do stuff on there that's very useful um i've been thinking about this is off topic but so like decking my like you know my space out with like all sorts of like front end tv media players but actually really complicated to like not spend a lot of money and have something that my wife and you know one day my child and like other people that just come over or whatever be able to use and not be like oh turn on this computer turn on the tv switch the hdmi port to this you know go over do this like it's really common i really want like a really nice i feel like there's a market there somebody like had a really well thought out customizable system to do all this maybe it's not possible maybe i'm pipe dreaming
所以我很喜欢这个。所以我用它在上面做一些非常有用的事情，嗯，我一直在想这个，虽然离题了，但就像把我的空间装饰成各种前端电视媒体播放器，但实际上要不花很多钱，并且拥有我妻子和，你知道，有一天我的孩子，以及其他过来的人之类的能够使用，而不是像“哦，打开这台电脑，打开电视，把 HDMI 端口切换到这个，你知道，走过去做这个”之类的，这真的很常见，我真的很想要一个非常好的，我觉得那里有一个市场，有人有一个非常深思熟虑的可定制系统来做所有这些，也许是不可能的，也许我在做白日梦
but yeah because i mean for for me for example example, I have the same problem where, you know, if you want to play the PlayStation, you have to switch over to HDMI too, and you have to know that. That right there is hard. Then you have to, like, turn on a PlayStation controller, boots up the PS3, all that stuff. Then if you want to use the PC, you have to go in the coffee table, get the wireless keyboard and mouse, switch over to pc you know turn on the computer which it's a laptop and we keep it closed so you have to like open the lid you know turn it on close the lid yeah it's all this stuff you know like the general like dvd
但是是的，因为我的意思是，对我来说，例如，我有同样的问题，你知道，如果你想玩 PlayStation，你必须切换到 HDMI 2，你必须知道这一点。那一点很难。然后你必须，像，打开一个 PlayStation 控制器，启动 PS3，所有这些东西。然后如果你想使用 PC，你必须去咖啡桌，拿到无线键盘和鼠标，切换到 PC，你知道，打开电脑，它是一台笔记本电脑，我们保持它关闭，所以你必须像打开盖子，你知道，打开它，关上盖子，是的，所有这些东西，你知道，像一般的 DVD
player playstation xbox like that is is okay but like if you get something i don't know if you ever used a roker and apple tv like something that but that did this like streaming really well and had like an integrated backend. So I knew it was going to work. Like there's other stuff like Western Digital makes something that's a front end. I think Roku even has some stuff. I mean, these people have things
播放器、PlayStation、Xbox 之类的，那还可以，但如果你得到一些东西，我不知道你是否用过 Roku 和 Apple TV，像那样，但做得很好，流媒体效果很好，并且有一个集成的后端。所以我知道它会工作。就像还有其他东西，比如 Western Digital 制造了一些前端的东西。我想 Roku 甚至有一些东西。我的意思是，这些人有东西
that'll stream on the front end and Xbox Media Center is close, but then I still have to get a compatible backend and make sure the right codecs are installed or the right conversion or run like something and make sure it stays updated. And it's just, I wish there was like some really nice low-cost like maybe you should write one on your raspberry pi that you
可以在前端流式传输，Xbox Media Center 很接近，但我仍然必须获得一个兼容的后端，并确保安装了正确的编解码器或正确的转换，或者运行类似的东西并确保它保持更新。这只是，我希望有一个非常好的低成本的，也许你应该在你的 Raspberry Pi 上写一个，你
will get eventually what day did somebody oh a friend of mine a colleague of mine at work he signed up for the raspberry pi around the same time I did maybe a month before and he got an email saying that they were gonna ship it to him in like a month and a half oh it's gonna be forever for you yeah so it's minimum month and a half so I'm thinking like in three months I'll have one when I signed up when he's of course it could be a million people in between so by programming through it on episode 100 yeah exactly I mean running on the raspberry pi
最终会得到的，哪天有人，哦，我的一个朋友，我在工作中的一个同事，他在我注册 Raspberry Pi 的同一时间注册了，也许早一个月，他收到一封电子邮件说他们会在一个半月内发货给他，哦，这对你来说将是永远，是的，所以至少是一个半月，所以我认为像三个月后我会有一个，当我注册时，当然中间可能有 100 万人，所以通过第 100 集编程，是的，完全正确，我的意思是运行在 Raspberry Pi 上
yeah by the time we run out of programming languages i feel like recently that it's one of those what is the thing like if you had talking about growth and like you try to count something like it would grow faster than you could count it so i feel like programming languages that way we there's a programming released more frequently than we do the show yeah so like we even if we keep going There's a programming released more frequently than we do the show. Yeah, totally. So, like, even if we keep going, like, we'll never – they grow faster than we do.
是的，当我们用完编程语言时，我觉得最近它是那种，是什么东西，就像如果你在谈论增长，你试图计算某样东西，它增长的速度比你计算的速度快，所以我感觉编程语言就是那样，我们，有一种编程语言发布的频率比我们做节目的频率高，是的，所以即使我们继续，有一种编程语言发布的频率比我们做节目的频率高。是的，完全同意。所以，即使我们继续，我们永远也不会——它们增长的速度比我们快。
And it's, like, even if the, like, you know, if we were omnipotent and the number, like, the number, let's say, wouldn't grow or would grow very slowly. But as people write in and tell us about new languages and things, like, our awareness, that number is growing much faster. Yeah, that's true and i don't think yeah that we're never seeming to catch up which is great for the show oh i mean great yeah it's bad for our queue but it's amazing for the show so all right well on to this week's topic so this isn't a language no it's not it's uh it's actually sort of I guess a process concept yeah yeah it's so build automation yeah so what is the one thing everybody thinks so when I heard this topic I thought of one thing make and make files make files it's just
而且，就像，即使，就像，你知道，如果我们是全能的，数字，比方说，不会增长或增长非常缓慢。但随着人们写信告诉我们新的语言和事情，就像，我们的意识，那个数字增长得快得多。是的，那是真的，我不认为，是的，我们似乎永远赶不上，这对节目来说很棒，哦，我的意思是棒，是的，这对我们的队列来说很糟糕，但对节目来说太棒了，所以好吧，进入本周的主题，所以这不是一种语言，不，它不是，它实际上是一种，我想是一个过程概念，是的，是的，它是，所以构建自动化，是的，所以每个人想到的那件事是什么，当我听到这个话题时，我想到了 make 和 makefile，makefile 只是
me I dread make file oh man somebody starts talking about make files and I just want to stick my fingers in my ear and go la la la la la la la la so bad you know if if I get an error in like, you know how most programs, if those of you out there have done like Linux stuff, they'll say, oh, you know, to install this, just download the zip file and then run, you know, dot slash configure and then make and then make install. Yeah.
我，我害怕 makefile，哦天哪，有人开始谈论 makefile，我只想把手指塞进耳朵里，然后“啦啦啦啦啦啦”，太糟糕了，你知道，如果，如果我在类似的地方得到一个错误，你知道大多数程序，如果你们中那些做过类似 Linux 东西的人，他们会说，哦，你知道，要安装这个，只需下载 zip 文件，然后运行，你知道，点斜杠 configure，然后 make，然后 make install。是的。
If any of those three fail, I give up. I just don't want to. Raise my hand. That's me. That's me. It could be like, It could be so specific. It could say, oh, make file line 31. This if should really
如果这三个中的任何一个失败，我就放弃。我只是不想。举手。那是我。那是我。它可能是，它可能是如此具体。它可能会说，哦，makefile 第 31 行。这个 if 真的应该
be an end if. And I won't even, it's like, forget it. I'm not touching it. Yeah. Or if it's like, sometimes you install a package and it's like, you don't do.slash configure, it's like something else. It's like, oh, you have to go in and enter this. Enter your platform type.
是一个 endif。我甚至不会，就像，算了吧。我不碰它。是的。或者如果它是，有时你安装一个包，它就像，你不做点斜杠 configure，它是别的东西。它就像，哦，你必须进去输入这个。输入你的平台类型。
Automaker. I'm done. But it is a very hard topic. I mean, building complex, we talk about many module, many people working on a common programming source base. And how do you get all of that to build down into one, let's call it a deliverable, an end item, a thing that you're going to use and run.
Automake。我完了。但这是一个非常难的话题。我的意思是，构建复杂的，我们谈论许多模块，许多人在一个共同的编程源代码库上工作。你如何让所有这些构建成一个，我们称之为可交付成果，一个最终项目，一个你将使用和运行的东西。
Yeah, yeah, totally. Yeah, I mean, it's completely vital. As painful as it is, there's just... If you think about it, you can do many build commands in a single command. Let's say you had three C++ files and you wanted to compile all of them into one object. You can do the "-c", and then the file names dash all right but like eventually you're gonna run into something where you have to do like many different things you have to follow some kind of recipe or like you need to build it for two systems yeah or like
是的，是的，完全同意。是的，我的意思是，这完全至关重要。尽管它很痛苦，但只是……如果你考虑一下，你可以在一个命令中执行许多构建命令。假设你有三个 C++ 文件，你想把它们全部编译成一个对象。你可以做“-c”，然后文件名，dash，好吧，但最终你会遇到必须做许多不同事情的情况，你必须遵循某种配方，或者你需要为两个系统构建它，是的，或者像
you need to build it with you know this library for math or possibly this library format yeah or you have two parts of it you have the math library and. You have the math library, and then you have the graphics library, and then maybe you have a third part like the executable. It's like combinatorial. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And it's like the executable needs a math library. Yeah, I mean, you need to have some way of controlling the build process. And making sure, so I've learned this the hard way,
你需要用，你知道，这个数学库或者可能是这个格式库来构建它，是的，或者你有它的两个部分，你有数学库和。你有数学库，然后你有图形库，然后也许你有第三部分，比如可执行文件。这就像组合。是的，是的，完全正确。而且就像可执行文件需要一个数学库。是的，我的意思是，你需要有一种控制构建过程的方法。并确保，所以我通过艰难的方式学到了这一点，
making sure everybody on the team is building it the same way. Yeah. So if you just let people like, for instance, like let's stick in the C++ world for a second. So like just use GCC to make it, right? Like, oh, I'm just going to do this on the command line. Like, well, what optimization level did you use if we're tracking down a timing problem or any other set of potential flags?
确保团队中的每个人都以同样的方式构建它。是的。所以如果你只是让人们，例如，让我们在 C++ 世界里停留一秒钟。所以就像只使用 GCC 来制作它，对吧？就像，哦，我只是要在命令行上做这个。好吧，如果你正在追踪一个计时问题或任何其他潜在标志集，你使用了什么优化级别？
Or worse of all, like different people have different things in their BashRC script or wherever. Stuff is happening that they're not exactly aware of or don't remember and tracking down. That happened to me and a colleague of mine. I was getting an error and nobody else on the team was getting the error.
或者最糟糕的是，不同的人在他们的 BashRC 脚本或任何地方有不同的东西。事情正在发生，他们并不完全清楚或不记得，并且追踪。那发生在我和一个同事身上。我得到了一个错误，团队中没有其他人得到这个错误。
And it was only me and I had submitted a fix, like a bug fix because I thought it was a bug. And it turned out they all had something additional in their setup script that I didn't't have and it turned out oh I don't know if it was a bug or not like it just we got into a debate about like well which way is the right way but for sure everybody needs to do it the same way yep yeah totally so we should probably go through the history this is uh this has a pretty like crazy mixed up history why it's such a crazy mess right now. It's grown very organically.
而且只有我，我提交了一个修复，就像一个错误修复，因为我以为那是一个错误。结果他们都在他们的设置脚本中有一些额外的东西，而我没有，结果，哦，我不知道那是不是一个错误，就像我们只是陷入了一场关于“哪种方式是正确方式”的辩论，但可以肯定的是，每个人都需要以同样的方式做，是的，是的，完全同意，所以我们可能应该回顾一下历史，这是，这有一个相当疯狂的混合历史，为什么它现在是一个如此疯狂的混乱。它增长得非常有机。
And I'm sure there's even stuff we're not even going to talk about. History is just kind of like a travel through time as opposed to a complete history because I'm sure there was Jason's make configuration script that you probably had that was personal and that may have been the very first one. So this is more of like an arrow through time yeah exactly yeah so and i don't even know which one of these two came first but the first ones that i know of are make which everyone you know if everyone here is typed make um is almost certainly using bsd make which is that's the one that everyone kind of uh uh should be familiar with then there's also g make which is GNU make and basically those two essentially
而且我相信甚至有一些我们甚至不会谈论的东西。历史就像是一次穿越时间的旅行，而不是一部完整的历史，因为我相信有 Jason 的 make 配置脚本，你可能有一个个人的，那可能是第一个。所以这更像是一支穿越时间的箭，是的，完全正确，是的，而且我甚至不知道这两个中哪一个先出现，但我知道的第一个是 make，每个人，你知道，如果这里的每个人都输入过 make，几乎肯定是在使用 BSD make，那是每个人都应该熟悉的那一个，然后还有 gmake，也就是 GNU make，基本上这两个本质上
do the same thing which is they you know they parse the make file and then they turn the make file into a bunch of commands and so we'll get into sort of make files and what those are and things like that later but they sort of process the make file directly so someone goes in by hand and writes the make file, and then these guys go through and, you know, as sort of interpreters, just as if you had written a Lua file or a Python file, these guys go through line by line and parse the make files. So make files there is kind of like the programming language of make files.
做同样的事情，就是它们，你知道，它们解析 makefile，然后它们把 makefile 变成一堆命令，所以我们稍后会进入 makefile 以及那些是什么之类的东西，但它们直接处理 makefile，所以有人手动进去编写 makefile，然后这些家伙进去，你知道，作为解释器，就像你写了一个 Lua 文件或 Python 文件一样，这些家伙逐行解析 makefile。所以 makefile 在那里有点像 makefile 的编程语言。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so in studying for this, it really brought to me me how much I, what is the right term, conflate? I put together the idea of Make and GCC. So GCC is an amazing set of software. It's so powerful. And in my mind, Make and GCC are kind of linked. They're kind of one and the same. But they're really not.
是的，完全正确。是的，所以在学习这个的过程中，它真的让我意识到我，什么是正确的术语，混淆？我把 Make 和 GCC 的想法放在了一起。所以 GCC 是一套令人惊叹的软件。它太强大了。在我的脑海里，Make 和 GCC 是联系在一起的。它们有点是一回事。但它们真的不是。
No, totally different. Yeah, so you can use Make to do all sorts of other things if you really wanted to in fact I might be like turning complete I'm not really sure but yeah it's close yeah yeah you can definitely do all sorts of crazy stuff with it for sure then there's so then you know people quickly realize that make files were kind of brutal it's all right then get very long very and they the hard part about it is that there's so many sort of variables
不，完全不同。是的，所以如果你真的想的话，你可以用 Make 做各种其他事情，事实上我可能是，图灵完备，我不确定，但是的，它很接近，是的，是的，你绝对可以用它做各种疯狂的事情，这是肯定的，然后，你知道，人们很快意识到 makefile 有点残酷，好吧，然后变得非常长，非常，而且关于它的困难部分是，有太多的变量
that you're defining and then you're also, like, defining all of these rules. So, a variable might be like, the flags for this program are dash O3
你正在定义，然后你也在，像，定义所有这些规则。所以，一个变量可能是，这个程序的标志是 dash O3
dash P dash G. That's a variable. That's not, those aren't the right ones. What? I'm just kidding. You're compiling it wrong.
dash P dash G。那是一个变量。那不是，那些不是正确的。什么？我只是开玩笑。你编译错了。
You totally got me. Totally got me. We're actually recording the podcast in the same room. And so Patrick could see the fear in my face. I was like, oh, no, Dennis. So that's a variable. And then you also have actual rules. So, for example, whenever you have to do something,
你完全抓住了我。完全抓住了我。我们实际上是在同一个房间里录制播客。所以 Patrick 可以看到我脸上的恐惧。我当时想，哦，不，Dennis。所以那是一个变量。然后你也有实际的规则。所以，例如，每当你必须做某事时，
whenever you have a rule called that ends in.cpp, call gcc, you know, the rule name, and then the rule name.o or something like that. And so make files have both of these sort of intertwined, you could put a rule here, you could put a variable variable there so these a lot of these make file code generators like automake and qmake and cmake they try to sort of have this like data definition kind of thing like cmake for example uses a key value pairs for defining all of your variables and so that makes it very easy to sort of visualize and see and they even have groupings of variables. So you can see, like, these are my compiler flag variables. These are my path, include path variables.
每当你有一个以 .cpp 结尾的规则时，调用 gcc，你知道，规则名称，然后是规则名称 .o 之类的东西。所以 makefile 既有这些交织在一起的东西，你可以把一个规则放在这里，你可以把一个变量放在那里，所以这些 makefile 代码生成器中的许多，比如 automake 和 qmake 和 cmake，它们试图有一种数据定义之类的东西，比如 cmake，例如，使用键值对来定义你所有的变量，所以这使得可视化和查看变得非常容易，而且它们甚至有变量的分组。所以你可以看到，像，这些是我的编译器标志变量。这些是我的路径，包含路径变量。
These are et cetera. And then CMake also has the CMakeList.txt file, which has the rules. But by kind of separating those two, it sort of makes it easier to understand. Yeah, so CMake also has, like, a GUI. Yeah. So if you want to, I mean, you don't have to, but it also makes it easier to represent. And then they make their own kind of intermediate file.
这些是等等。然后 CMake 也有 CMakeList.txt 文件，它有规则。但通过某种方式将两者分开，它使理解变得更容易。是的，所以 CMake 也有，像，一个 GUI。是的。所以如果你想，我的意思是，你不必，但它也使表示变得更容易。然后他们制作他们自己的一种中间文件。
Like, this is like the CMake description of what you are. So like you say, certain sorting is enforced or certain groupings are kind of taken care of. Yep. And then from then, you can kind of compile,
就像，这是 CMake 对你是什么的描述。所以就像你说，强制执行某种排序或某种分组被照顾到。是的。然后从那时起，你可以编译，
interpret, translate that CMake file into a normal Makefile. Right. And then it handles a lot of the boilerplate code, the organization, the complex branching structures you might want. Yeah, totally. So that was sort of like the second phase.
解释，将那个 CMake 文件翻译成一个普通的 Makefile。没错。然后它处理了很多样板代码，组织，你可能想要的复杂分支结构。是的，完全同意。所以那有点像第二阶段。
They got into the automake, CMake world. That's sort of the next generation. Code writing code. Yeah, it's getting scary. Code writing code. We must go deeper. That compiles other code. So now the most modern is sort of this ant, maven kind of stuff. And so these are normally associated with like Java.
他们进入了 automake，CMake 世界。那是下一代。代码编写代码。是的，这变得很可怕。代码编写代码。我们必须深入。那编译其他代码。所以现在最现代的是类似 ant，maven 之类的东西。所以这些通常与类似 Java 的东西相关联。
So kind of like around the time like Java was coming out because Make and GCC were kind of like kind of intermixed. And so this is an opportunity for people to kind of say, well, we're doing Java, so it's a different methodology we're going to kind of put in. And these ones actually take it a step further. So not only are they sort of at a higher level as CMake and QMake and things like that, but especially in the case of Maven, it's also in the cloud. So you can say, hey, I need the pill, the Python imaging library.
所以有点像 Java 出来的时候，因为 Make 和 GCC 有点混合在一起。所以这是一个机会，让人们说，好吧，我们正在做 Java，所以这是我们将要采用的一种不同的方法。而且这些实际上更进一步。所以它们不仅处于像 CMake 和 QMake 之类的高级水平，而且特别是在 Maven 的情况下，它也在云端。所以你可以说，嘿，我需要 pill，Python 图像库。
Your Maven file can say that. And it can actually go to the cloud, find a copy of the Python Imaging Library, pull it onto your machine and build it without you having to distribute that with your code. It's like the idea of
你的 Maven 文件可以那样说。而且它实际上可以去云端，找到 Python 图像库的副本，把它拉到你的机器上并构建它，而不需要你把它和你的代码一起分发。这就像
adding that, pulling it in from the internet is in the build file and so that I think is really awesome because one of the hardest things is is You know distributing your code and then realizing like oh I was using this version of free image And now like Ubuntu 13 is on that version of free image and my make file doesn't work anymore Yeah, and like knowing like if you can have it pull which I think it's able to do like pull the latest version right yeah I keep going the latest version of
添加那个，从互联网上拉取它是在构建文件中，所以我认为这真的很棒，因为最困难的事情之一是，你知道分发你的代码，然后意识到，哦，我正在使用这个版本的 free image，现在 Ubuntu 13 使用那个版本的 free image，我的 makefile 不再工作了，是的，而且知道，如果可以的话，让它拉取，我认为它能够做到，就像拉取最新版本的
Python image library like it could be confusing in some sense like oh why did this not work or why did it stop working or like all these things but on the other hand like it means that if your end user goes and grabs the latest stuff you know it'll work and then if something does break you can go ahead and just fix it yeah and if it doesn't, you know it'll work. And then if something does break, you can go ahead and just fix it. And if it doesn't or you don't want to because there's some drastic change, you can always lock it in a set version, and at least it's explicit. Like, it's not that it was whatever Python imaging library I pulled on June the 2nd of the year.
Python 图像库，在某种意义上可能会令人困惑，哦，为什么这个不起作用，或者为什么它停止工作，或者所有这些事情，但另一方面，这意味着如果你的最终用户去获取最新的东西，你知道它会工作，然后如果确实有什么东西坏了，你可以继续修复它，是的，如果它不工作，你知道它会工作。然后如果确实有什么东西坏了，你可以继续修复它。如果它不工作或者你不想，因为有一些剧烈的变化，你总是可以把它锁定在一个设定的版本，至少它是明确的。就像，它不是我 6 月 2 日拉取的任何 Python 图像库。
No, it's just like, you know, version 1.6.3.4.2.1a. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, so I mean, and this keeps you from running into like shared library hell or DLL hell, as Windows people call it, where, you know, you were using this version of free image and you included it in your make file. And so even though this person has a higher version, which would have worked, now they have to build your version too for your app. Oh, that points out another pet peeve of mine. People have version numbers, and they'll have an upper bound on the version number. And even though there's no reason, it's just that was the highest version that was around when they were.
不，它只是，你知道，版本 1.6.3.4.2.1a。是的，是的，完全正确。是的，所以我的意思是，这可以防止你陷入共享库地狱或 DLL 地狱，正如 Windows 人所称的那样，你知道，你正在使用这个版本的 free image，并且你把它包含在你的 makefile 中。所以即使这个人有一个更高的版本，本来是可以工作的，现在他们也必须为你的应用程序构建你的版本。哦，那指出了我的另一个心头大患。人们有版本号，他们会对版本号有一个上限。即使没有理由，那只是他们当时周围的最高版本。
And you have a higher version, and you have to go in and edit to allow your higher version because you know it'll work, and you can't find the older version. Yeah, this is brutal, man. Sorry. No, no, it's cool. And so now also, you know, sort of in parallel with the AntMaven stuff is you're starting to see more of the build process integrated with the IDE. So for example, if you use Eclipse, if you create a new C++ project, and you drag a bunch of files into some folders there, Eclipse is smart enough to sort of look
而且你有一个更高的版本，你必须进去编辑以允许你的更高版本，因为你知道它会工作，而且你找不到旧版本。是的，这很残酷，伙计。抱歉。不，不，这很酷。所以现在也，你知道，有点与 AntMaven 的东西并行，你开始看到更多的构建过程与 IDE 集成。所以例如，如果你使用 Eclipse，如果你创建一个新的 C++ 项目，并且你把一堆文件拖到那里的一些文件夹中，Eclipse 足够聪明，可以某种程度上查看
at the files, you know, index the files, come up there. Eclipse is smart enough to sort of look at the files, index the files, come up with the dependencies, and do all that good stuff. Making things easier. Yeah, totally. Although I guess then when things go wrong, maybe it'll be like assembly. Nobody will know what the underlying,
这些文件，你知道，索引这些文件，想出，Eclipse 足够聪明，可以查看这些文件，索引这些文件，想出依赖关系，并做所有那些好的事情。让事情变得更容易。是的，完全同意。虽然我想当事情出错时，也许它会像汇编一样。没有人会知道底层，
how to get stuff built actually works. Yeah, I've had things bomb in Eclipse, and it's just been brutal. I mean, it comes down to like you have to remove files and add them back or like remove a file. You keep removing files until it works and then it gets ugly. Or when it's like tied in as well with source control and then like stuff gets all like really bad, really fast. That's so bad sometimes. Yeah. So that's the history.
如何让东西构建实际上是如何工作的。是的，我在 Eclipse 中遇到过事情崩溃，这简直太残酷了。我的意思是，归结为就像你必须删除文件并把它们加回来，或者像删除一个文件。你不断删除文件直到它工作，然后它变得很丑。或者当它与源代码控制结合得很好，然后东西变得非常糟糕，非常快。那有时太糟糕了。是的。所以这就是历史。
As you can tell, it's still kind of a hard thing to deal with. But it's something that as software engineers and coders, you know, we have to deal with on a daily basis. Yeah, you really got to know. It's good to be aware of it. And you already kind of talked about, but I mean, like, if we didn't have this, it would be horrible. Yeah, that's right.
正如你所看到的，这仍然是一件很难处理的事情。但这是我们作为软件工程师和编码人员，你知道，每天都必须处理的事情。是的，你真的必须知道。意识到这一点很好。而且你已经谈到了，但我的意思是，就像，如果我们没有这个，那将是可怕的。是的，那是对的。
This is better than the alternative. And there really are a lot of features that these things bring. So you kind of hit, like, dependency. So, like, there's the concept that if i depend on module b which depends on module c i depend on module c well you say no you don't you just depend on module b yeah yeah but module b like there's this you have to kind of walk this graph yeah and it's not just like one to one to one i mean they can get you know to many to many and so you could be expanding like i depend on one project which depends on five projects which depends on each
这总比其他选择要好。这些东西确实带来了很多功能。所以你有点像遇到了依赖关系。比如，有一个概念是，如果我依赖模块 B，而模块 B 依赖模块 C，那么我就依赖模块 C。好吧，你说不，你没有，你只是依赖模块 B。是的，是的，但是模块 B，就像你必须遍历这个图一样。是的，它不仅仅是一对一的关系，我的意思是它们可以变成多对多的关系，所以你可能会扩展，比如我依赖一个项目，它依赖五个项目，而这五个项目中的每一个
of those depend on two or three more you get this expansion that can get really big really really fast yeah and so something has to kind of go through and understand like oh okay I need to build this first and this second and this third and kind of yeah come up with that whole structure yeah I mean imagine like if you did this yourself let's say you um just had a dot sh like some shell script that just built all of your files. And then you had, let's say, like a graphics engine and a music engine, and then your game engine with the executable in it, right? So you started off with like, it built the graphics, and it built the music, then it built the game. But then for whatever reason, all of a sudden, you know, you decided
又依赖两三个项目，你会得到这种增长，它会变得非常非常快。是的，所以必须有人去梳理并理解，哦，好的，我需要先构建这个，然后是第二个，第三个，并想出整个结构。是的，我的意思是，想象一下如果你自己做这件事，假设你只有一个 .sh 文件，也就是某种 shell 脚本，它只是构建了你所有的文件。然后你有一个，比如说，图形引擎和音乐引擎，然后是带有可执行文件的游戏引擎，对吧？所以你开始时，它构建了图形，构建了音乐，然后构建了游戏。但后来由于某种原因，突然间，你知道，你决定
that, oh, I want there to be, like, I want the graphics engine to depend on the music for some reason. Like, if a certain music's playing, I want to play an animation, and instead of writing an API, I'm just going to have, like, the graphics code import the music. Bad coder. That terrible code. Don't ever do that. Bad coder.
哦，我希望图形引擎因为某种原因依赖于音乐。比如，如果正在播放特定的音乐，我想播放一个动画，而不是编写一个 API，我只是让图形代码导入音乐。糟糕的程序员。那真是糟糕的代码。永远不要那样做。糟糕的程序员。
But now you have to, like, rearrange your shell script. And, you know, in this case, with just three things, you would just move it down. But you can imagine this getting way, way out of hand. And also, your shell script doesn't self-document. The fact that things are in a certain order, you know in your head that the graphics engine has to be built first, but the shell script just has three lines.
但现在你必须重新整理你的 shell 脚本。而且，你知道，在这种情况下，只有三件事，你只需把它移到下面。但你可以想象这会变得多么失控。而且，你的 shell 脚本没有自文档化。事情按特定顺序排列的事实，你知道在你的脑海里图形引擎必须先构建，但 shell 脚本只有三行。
I mean, it doesn't, unless you write your own documentation there, it doesn't encode that one thing depends on the other. Yeah, that's right. And even just having a list of what all the things you depend on. Like you said, so if you're going to email somebody else your source code or post it up to a source control somewhere, you know, then that
我的意思是，除非你在那里写下你自己的文档，否则它不会编码出某件事依赖于另一件事。是的，没错。甚至只是列出你依赖的所有东西。就像你说的，如果你要通过电子邮件把源代码发给别人，或者把它发布到某个源代码控制系统中，你知道，那么
way you can kind of say, like, hey, this is all the other stuff you need as well. And some languages have kind of batteries included features that make that easier than others. Other thing you talked about a little is is the kind of cross compilation or even just like for 64-bit versus 32-bit or you know like i need big indian versus little indian like all these things like you know you may support all of those features in your program but you got to pass the appropriate flags to you, to the compiler, to possibly the operating system, like, you know, all these different things. And you, sure, you can do that, right? Like, you could write that file, but it's much nicer to have a tool to help you
这样你就可以说，嘿，这也是你需要的所有其他东西。有些语言有内置的功能，使这比其他语言更容易。你谈到的另一件事是交叉编译，或者甚至是 64 位与 32 位的对比，或者你知道，我需要大端序与小端序，所有这些事情，你知道，你可能在你的程序中支持所有这些功能，但你必须将适当的标志传递给编译器，可能还有操作系统，你知道，所有这些不同的东西。而且，当然，你可以做到，对吧？比如，你可以编写那个文件，但有一个工具来帮助你
write those things and to keep them organized. Yeah, and in, like, in the same way as most languages are written in themselves, you know, we've talked about that every now and then where, you know, Python comes batteries included. So a lot of the things in Python, like the entire standard library, is written in Python. So in the same way, a lot of, you know, a lot of make files reference things that are also written in make that just kind of come standard. your example of big indian versus little indian they've already done the grunt work of calling the sort of crazy kernel level libraries to figure out if your machine is big indian without you manually specifying it and you just have to say like is big indian or something and some you know the make file you know program writers have dealt with that problem for you so that's a good point because it's depending on what machine you're compiling it on,
编写这些东西并保持它们的组织性会好得多。是的，就像大多数语言本身就是用它们自己编写的一样，你知道，我们偶尔会谈到这一点，Python 是内置功能的。所以 Python 中的很多东西，比如整个标准库，都是用 Python 编写的。所以同样地，很多 makefile 引用了也是用 make 编写的东西，它们只是作为标准提供的。你关于大端序与小端序的例子，他们已经完成了调用那种疯狂的内核级库来弄清楚你的机器是否是大端序的繁重工作，而无需你手动指定，你只需要说类似“是大端序吗”之类的，而且你知道，makefile 程序编写者已经为你处理了那个问题，所以这是一个很好的观点，因为它取决于你在什么机器上编译它，
not just compiling it for. Yeah, I mean, you might say, like, I just want to compile it for this machine, whatever it is. And so if you don't know what OS call to make to learn all of the intrinsic properties of this machine, the Makefile guys, they do. And they've done all that. So yeah, another big part of makefiles are using conditional logic. So for example, FFmpeg is a popular MPEG encoding, decoding library.
不仅仅是为它编译。是的，我的意思是，你可能会说，我只是想为这台机器编译它，不管它是什么。所以如果你不知道要进行什么操作系统调用来了解这台机器的所有内在属性，Makefile 的家伙们，他们知道。他们已经完成了所有这些。所以，是的，makefile 的另一个重要部分是使用条件逻辑。例如，FFmpeg 是一个流行的 MPEG 编码、解码库。
And they're constantly under fire from the the, was it RIAA? Oh, okay. And other like organizations that are against sort of re-encoding of music and things like that. So what FFmpeg has done is they've structured their make file in such a way where you can pass a flag called, I think it's enable non-free, dash, dash, enable non-free. And if you pass that flag, they'll give you all of the codecs, like MPEG-4, which are sort of in dispute and are not sort of like are under patents and things like that.
他们经常受到来自，是 RIAA 吗？哦，好的。以及其他反对重新编码音乐之类的组织。所以 FFmpeg 所做的是，他们以这样一种方式构建了他们的 makefile，你可以传递一个标志，我想是 enable non-free，破折号，破折号，enable non-free。如果你传递那个标志，他们会给你所有的编解码器，比如 MPEG-4，它们在某种程度上是有争议的，并且受到专利之类的限制。
If you want to be on the safe side, let's say you're a big corporation and you're worried about getting sued and things like that, you can not put in that enable non-free flag in the make file. DAN GALPINIUK, And then it won't be in your code. DAN GALPINIUK, And then that stuff will be out of the code. And so this is really important for FFmpeg, because they want to make sure that not only can you not use this, but it's literally not in your code.
如果你想稳妥起见，假设你是一家大公司，你担心被起诉之类的，你可以在 makefile 中不放入那个 enable non-free 标志。DAN GALPINIUK，然后它就不会在你的代码里了。DAN GALPINIUK，然后那些东西就会从代码中剔除。所以这对 FFmpeg 来说非常重要，因为他们想确保不仅你不能使用它，而且它实际上根本不在你的代码中。
Like the code's not in your object, so you can't get in trouble. DAN GALPINIUK, Yeah. No, that's pretty good. So we already kind of, I think we spoiled most of the strengths talking about features. But one in here that is good that's pretty good. So we already kind of, I think we spoiled most of the strengths talking about features. But one in here that is good that you're talking about is also, you know, even if you could write shell scripts for all this stuff because you are an awesome programmer, which you are.
就像代码不在你的目标文件中一样，所以你不会惹上麻烦。DAN GALPINIUK，是的。不，那很不错。所以我们已经，我想我们在谈论功能时已经剧透了大部分优势。但这里有一个很好的，非常好的。所以我们已经，我想我们在谈论功能时已经剧透了大部分优势。但这里有一个很好的，你正在谈论的，也是，你知道，即使你可以为所有这些东西编写 shell 脚本，因为你是一个很棒的程序员，你确实是。
Likewise. No, that's not true. You're wearing a Nintendo controller t-shirt, so I have no, my argument is invalid. So parallelizing and distributing. I mean, this is something that if you were going to do on your own, it would be like you'd have to write your own library. I mean, it'd just be crazy. But here the make files can handle like once they know the dependency graph
彼此彼此。不，那不是真的。你穿着一件任天堂控制器的 T 恤，所以我没有，我的论点无效。所以并行化和分布式。我的意思是，如果你要自己做这件事，那就像你必须编写自己的库一样。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。但在这里，makefile 可以处理，一旦它们知道了依赖图
and they walk this, they can say this build can go on on a different machine than this build because it's not needed until this step. And so it can kind of chop and slice and dice it, you know, eight ways between here and there and say like, this is our plan. This is how we're going to compile everything. And so use things like distcc, distributed gcc, like these kinds of things.
并且它们遍历了这个图，它们就可以说这个构建可以在与这个构建不同的机器上进行，因为它直到这一步才被需要。所以它可以把任务切分，你知道，在各处以八种方式进行，并说，这是我们的计划。这就是我们将如何编译所有东西。所以使用像 distcc、分布式 gcc 这样的东西，像这些东西。
And, or even just, you know, you have multiple cores. Handling all this is very complicated and can be quite complicated. And make files can really help you with that. Yeah, totally. Like if you've ever done the whole like configure, make, make, install stuff, you know, unless somebody has written their make file wrong, but assuming that someone's put
而且，或者甚至只是，你知道，你有多个核心。处理所有这些非常复杂，而且可能相当复杂。而 makefile 真的可以帮助你做到这一点。是的，完全正确。就像如果你曾经做过整个 configure、make、make install 之类的东西，你知道，除非有人写错了他们的 makefile，但假设有人已经把
the dependencies where they should have and everything, you can replace that make with make space dash j and then the number of cores. Oh, that's obvious. Dash j for JSON. Yeah, for jobs. Oh, for JSON. Yeah, indeed. number of cores. Oh, that's obvious. Dash J for JSON. For jobs. Oh, for JSON. Yeah, indeed.
依赖项放在了它们应该在的地方，一切都准备好了，你可以用 make space dash j 然后是核心数量来替换那个 make。哦，那很明显。Dash j 代表 JSON。是的，代表 jobs。哦，代表 JSON。是的，确实。核心数量。哦，那很明显。Dash J 代表 JSON。代表 jobs。哦，代表 JSON。是的，确实。
So you can have like eight Jasons in hamster cages just like running away in parallel. I want a JSON in my computer to compile my code for me. Oh, that'd be pretty awesome. That'd be a horrible job. I want a JSON in my computer, too. Oh, OK. I don't know why.
所以你可以有八个 JSON 在仓鼠笼里并行运行。我想要一个 JSON 在我的电脑里为我编译代码。哦，那会很棒。那将是一份可怕的工作。我也想要一个 JSON 在我的电脑里。哦，好的。我不知道为什么。
That sounded really vain. I would like a JSON inside of every computer. Actually, I just want the argonauts. JSON could stay out, but I need an argonaut in every computer. Isn't that like a 1 and an argonaut 0s, like the biggest number ever? You lost me. I think you went over my head.
那听起来真的很虚荣。我希望每台电脑里都有一个 JSON。其实我只想要阿尔戈英雄。JSON 可以待在外面，但我需要每台电脑里都有一个阿尔戈英雄。那不是像 1 和阿尔戈英雄个 0，是有史以来最大的数字吗？你把我弄糊涂了。我想你说的太深奥了。
I'm searching the Google now. Yes, an argonaut is 1 followed by an argonaut 0s. I'm totally making that up. So you can do make-j8 for example, and it'll automatically know sort of like what depends on what, and it'll use all eight of your cores. Wikipedia says
我正在搜索谷歌。是的，一个阿尔戈英雄是 1 后面跟着阿尔戈英雄个 0。我完全是编出来的。所以你可以做 make-j8，例如，它会自动知道什么依赖于什么，它会使用你的所有八个核心。维基百科说
Argonaut is an ancient Greek civilization. And I want eight of them. Oh, there is a sailor in Greek mythology, Jason and the Argonauts yes indeed indeed okay so sorry continue oh man but yeah so you could totally make your uh make your makes blaze super fast make make you can make your make makes um yeah and and also as pat Patrick was alluding to, there's disk CC, which is,
阿尔戈英雄是古希腊文明。我想要八个。哦，希腊神话里有一个水手，杰森和阿尔戈英雄，是的，确实，确实，好的，抱歉，继续，哦天哪，但是是的，所以你可以完全让你的 make 变得超级快，make make，你可以让你的 make make，嗯，是的，而且正如 Patrick 所暗示的，有 disk CC，这是
that's actually kind of a little tricky to set up. So, you know, unless you're doing a ton of building, you know, I wouldn't go that route. Or you have a server farm. Yeah, yeah, but if you, or you want to use EC2 for that, if you have lots of money. But yeah, you could totally install disk CC.
这实际上有点难以设置。所以，你知道，除非你做了大量的构建，你知道，我不会走那条路。或者你有一个服务器农场。是的，是的，但如果你，或者你想为此使用 EC2，如果你有很多钱的话。但是的，你可以完全安装 disk CC。
It's like a wrapper around GCC. And let's say you had, like, four computers in the house. You could put DiskCCD, which is the DiskCC daemon, on all four of those computers. And then when you did make, I think it's like, I forgot the flag, but there's a way you can put into make where it will actually farm out your make, which is pretty awesome. And you also won't have to heat your house. That's like, I forgot the flag, but there's a way you can put into make where it'll actually farm out your make, which is pretty awesome. And you also won't have to heat your house. That's true, yeah.
它就像 GCC 的一个包装器。假设你家里有四台电脑。你可以把 DiskCCD，也就是 DiskCC 守护进程，放在所有那四台电脑上。然后当你运行 make 时，我想是，我忘了那个标志了，但有一种方法可以放入 make 中，它实际上会分发你的 make，这非常棒。而且你也不用给你的房子供暖。那是，我忘了那个标志了，但有一种方法可以放入 make 中，它实际上会分发你的 make，这非常棒。而且你也不用给你的房子供暖。那是真的，是的。
You can just heat the house with induction from your processors that are just on fire. Or, like you said, if you're rich and you have a lot of money, instead of starting up this on EC2, you could just send the money to us and Jason will compile it for you. Yeah, exactly. There will be it for you. Ridiculous. So also, I mean, it's another layer between you and the compiler. And so that can kind of obscure things, which is great. I mean, you want to have an abstraction. But at the same time, it can kind of hide errors from you. Yep, totally. Yeah, I can't count the number of times that I've gotten errors.
你可以只用处理器产生的感应热量来给房子供暖，它们只是着火了。或者，就像你说的，如果你很有钱，有很多钱，而不是在 EC2 上启动这个，你可以直接把钱寄给我们，Jason 会为你编译它。是的，完全正确。它会为你完成。荒谬。所以，我的意思是，这是你和编译器之间的另一层。所以这可能会掩盖一些东西，这很好。我的意思是，你想要有一个抽象。但同时，它可能会向你隐藏错误。是的，完全正确。是的，我数不清我遇到过多少次错误。
And just I tried to compile some open source app. And I get an error. And, you know, there might say, like, something really crazy. Like, oh, can't find, like, some file with, like't find some file with 10 different sets of ellipses in front, because make has stepped through all these directories, and then now is referring to a file relative to somewhere else that I don't even know of. So yeah, it can definitely make things really hard to debug. Because of all that, you end up with the one guy who you know
我只是尝试编译一些开源应用程序。然后我得到了一个错误。而且，你知道，可能会说，一些非常疯狂的东西。比如，哦，找不到，像，一些文件，前面有 10 组省略号，因为 make 已经遍历了所有这些目录，现在正在引用一个相对于我甚至不知道的某个地方的文件。所以是的，它绝对会让调试变得非常困难。因为所有这些，你最终会得到那个你认识的
who's really good at this. Yeah, exactly. He's the only one and he helps you put some awesome code in your make file that you do not understand and nobody else has either and then eventually that person leaves forgets whatever and you end up with what i call in the code black magic yeah that's the those lines of the code that you have in a lot of historic legacy programs which nobody quite knows why they're there or what they do but don't take them out or it will break. Yeah.
非常擅长这个的人。是的，完全正确。他是唯一一个，他帮你把一些很棒的代码放进你的 makefile 里，你不理解，别人也不理解，然后最终那个人离开了，忘记了什么，你最终得到了我所说的代码黑魔法。是的，那些你在许多历史遗留程序中拥有的代码行，没人确切知道它们为什么在那里或者它们做什么，但不要把它们删掉，否则它会崩溃。是的。
Yeah, I actually saw something in a makefile where it said, like, error one is okay here, and then it returned two. And I'm like, should I be worried about this? The answer is probably yes. So, yeah, fortunately, there's a lot of tools to sort of help you navigate the painful experience that is the makefile process. Yep. You know, one of them is automake. Automake's very popular.
是的，我实际上在 makefile 中看到过一些东西，它说，比如，错误 1 在这里是可以的，然后它返回了 2。我心想，我应该担心这个吗？答案很可能是肯定的。所以，是的，幸运的是，有很多工具可以帮助你应对 makefile 过程带来的痛苦体验。是的。你知道，其中之一是 automake。Automake 非常流行。
Actually, do you know anything about automake? Like, I've used it a lot. Yeah, same here. Never used it. Oh, really? I've gone in and, like, because sometimes it tells you type automake. Oh, okay. I've gone in and like, because sometimes it tells you type automake. And automake, it's such a complicated mess. But automake creates the configure that then you have to call to create the make file.
其实，你知道关于 automake 的任何事情吗？比如，我用过很多次。是的，我也是。从来没用过。哦，真的吗？我进去过，比如，因为有时它会告诉你输入 automake。哦，好的。我进去过，比如，因为有时它会告诉你输入 automake。而 automake，它是一个如此复杂的混乱。但 automake 创建了 configure，然后你必须调用它来创建 makefile。
Oh, man. That you have to call make on. Yeah, it's crazy. I need to go take pain medicine. Yeah. Somehow automake is better than writing make files. I don't get it. But one that I have used a ton, and I swear by it, I think it's great, is CMake.
哦，天哪。你必须调用 make。是的，这太疯狂了。我需要去吃止痛药。是的。不知何故，automake 比编写 makefile 要好。我不明白。但我用过很多次，并且我发誓它很好，我认为它很棒，那就是 CMake。
You know, I mentioned most of the good things about CMake with separating the variables and all that. But CMake's a great one. I've used a little bit of QMake for doing, like, QT apps. Oh, okay. All right. That's where I've seen it before. Yeah, yeah. I think NMake is the one that Microsoft puts out.
你知道，我提到了 CMake 的大部分优点，比如分离变量等等。但 CMake 是一个很好的工具。我用过一点 QMake 来做，比如，QT 应用程序。哦，好的。好的。我以前见过它。是的，是的。我认为 NMake 是微软推出的那个。
Yeah, yeah. I've used that. So pretty much star make. Yeah, yeah. Ismake is the one that Microsoft puts out. Yes. So pretty much star make. Is there any character here? Make? Yeah, exactly. You need a jmake? Yeah, oh yeah, it should be the next one. Argomake. So, yeah. As we mentioned, Ant and Maven
是的，是的。我用过那个。所以几乎是 star make。是的，是的。Ismake 是微软推出的那个。是的。所以几乎是 star make。这里有任何字符吗？Make？是的，完全正确。你需要一个 jmake？是的，哦，是的，它应该是下一个。Argomake。所以，是的。正如我们提到的，Ant 和 Maven
are tools. There's also premake which is kind of interesting because it uses Lua, which we talked about in the last episode. Yeah. So you actually write Lua code that generates the make files. And I've used premake. It's decent. I still prefer CMake, but premake is good too. Playing favorites over here. Yeah, exactly.
是工具。还有 premake，这很有趣，因为它使用 Lua，我们在上一集谈到过。是的。所以你实际上编写了生成 makefile 的 Lua 代码。我用过 premake。它还不错。我仍然更喜欢 CMake，但 premake 也不错。在这里偏袒某一方。是的，完全正确。
So one of the things where they're kind of like, you know, sticking with our typical outline, I guess, we're trying to come up with some uses. We talked about, I mean, obviously to help build your file, that's the main use of a build system. But some things, you know, to kind of give you guys nuggets of inspiration, the things to think about, things you may never heard about. You may say, oh, this is old hat, Jason and Patrick, and like, oh, that's great. But some of the newfangled things that young whippersnappers are using, you know, like
所以其中一件事是他们有点像，你知道，坚持我们典型的大纲，我想，我们正在尝试提出一些用途。我们谈到了，我的意思是，显然是为了帮助构建你的文件，这是构建系统的主要用途。但有些事情，你知道，为了给你们提供一些灵感，你们可能从未听说过的事情。你可能会说，哦，这是老生常谈了，Jason 和 Patrick，比如，哦，那太棒了。但一些年轻人正在使用的新奇事物，你知道，比如
continuous integration, right? So, you know, the idea that, yeah, you might be able to type GCC, blah, blah, blah, really fast. But, you know, one thing is that you might not type it every time you make a code change or every time you push a change even. And so more and more it's important, the idea of, you know, building your system continuously with the code that's checked into the repository.
持续集成，对吧？所以，你知道，这个想法是，是的，你可能能够非常快地输入 GCC，等等。但是，你知道，有一件事是，你可能不会在你每次进行代码更改或每次推送更改时都输入它。所以越来越重要的是，你知道，用签入存储库的代码持续构建你的系统的想法。
Like what is it? You know, is it is it? Is it successfully built? Will it run the unit tests? Does it have unit tests? Yes is the right answer there. Does it have system tests? Does it have end-to-end tests? Does it have all these kinds of tests? To put what Patrick
比如它是什么？你知道，它是吗？它是吗？它构建成功了吗？它会运行单元测试吗？它有单元测试吗？是的，这是正确的答案。它有系统测试吗？它有端到端测试吗？它有所有这些种类的测试吗？把 Patrick
is saying more explicitly, let's say you have Subversion or Git or something like that. You can actually write something on your server side. I think it's called a hook, a Git or Subversion hook, where every time somebody checks in code, it runs the make file. And then it runs make test, and then it runs make system test. This is perfect.
所说的更明确一点，假设你有 Subversion 或 Git 之类的东西。你实际上可以在你的服务器端写一些东西。我想它叫钩子，Git 或 Subversion 钩子，每当有人签入代码时，它就会运行 makefile。然后它运行 make test，然后它运行 make system test。这太完美了。
I just say a bunch of words, and then you executive summarize it for me. I do need you in my computer. I can write an email, and then you can write TLDR. All right. I actually only recently found out about continuous integration stuff because that's something I hadn't been privy to until recently. It is pretty awesome. Actually, I got the email nobody wants to get,
我只是说了一堆话，然后你为我总结。我确实需要你在我的电脑里。我可以写一封电子邮件，然后你可以写 TLDR。好的。我其实直到最近才发现持续集成之类的东西，因为那是我直到最近才接触到的。它确实很棒。其实我收到了没人想收到的电子邮件，
which is the, oh, you broke the build. You broke the continuous integration. Yeah, you submitted code that now causes everyone else to... But that doesn't happen if you have perfect unit tests and perfect peer review. Yeah. Which everybody has. Of course. Nobody ever makes mistakes.
那就是，哦，你破坏了构建。你破坏了持续集成。是的，你提交的代码现在导致其他人……但如果你有完美的单元测试和完美的同行评审，这种情况就不会发生。是的。每个人都有。当然。没人会犯错。
No. Yeah, yeah, definitely. I don't. That's a lie. I can't remember last i do regularly i also have terrible memory the worst is i got an email because i did this and i got an email not from my own team for breaking the build but from another team who depended on our team oh those are the worst yeah then they're like hey hey what are you doing and they like we are a little bit more sheltered in how we do stuff but they have like you know they have to meet certain requirements or in the minutes like when something breaks it's like a big deal for them and like i broke it nice so yeah i broke something and just
不。是的，是的，绝对。我不会。那是谎言。我不记得上次我定期做这件事了，我的记忆力也很差，最糟糕的是我收到了一封电子邮件，因为我做了这件事，我收到的电子邮件不是来自我自己的团队，而是来自依赖我们团队的另一个团队，哦，那些是最糟糕的，是的，然后他们就像，嘿，嘿，你在做什么，他们就像我们做事情的方式更受保护，但他们有，你知道，他们必须满足某些要求，或者在几分钟内，当某件事崩溃时，这对他们来说是一件大事，就像我把它弄坏了，太好了，所以是的，我弄坏了一些东西，只是
in a terrible twist of fate or coincidence um it happened to be the hour that they were cutting like their release for the month oh and i just happened to break their stuff like, you know, only minutes before. Oh, tsk, tsk, tsk. Yeah, I actually got a phone call. Like they called my cell phone. Oh, wow. It was not pretty. You know, the alternative to that is like, you know, they cut the release
在命运或巧合的糟糕转折中，嗯，碰巧是他们要进行本月发布的那一小时，哦，我碰巧在几分钟前弄坏了他们的东西。哦，啧啧啧。是的，我实际上接到了一个电话。就像他们打我的手机。哦，哇。那可不好看。你知道，那的替代方案是，你知道，他们进行了发布
and then it's broken to the customer. So still Makefile is incredibly useful for that kind of stuff. And also, you know, for source distribution or package management systems, so things that are going to hold for people on all sorts of platforms and versions of the OS and all this, and for them to be able to download from a common area. So like Ubuntu software, you go in there and say, I want more apps,
然后它对客户来说是坏的。所以 Makefile 对那种事情仍然非常有用。而且，你知道，对于源代码分发或包管理系统，所以那些将为各种平台和操作系统版本的人保留的东西，以及让他们能够从公共区域下载的东西。就像 Ubuntu 软件，你进去说，我想要更多的应用程序，
or I guess applications. Here's my software. I'm going to download it. So they can get compiled for your system. Sometimes they're pre-built. Sometimes you can have the people build it themselves so that it can be specific for their platform and highly optimized.
或者我想是应用程序。这是我的软件。我要下载它。所以它们可以为你的系统编译。有时它们是预先构建的。有时你可以让人自己构建它，以便它可以针对他们的平台进行特定优化。
Yeah, totally, totally. Well, that's all I got for this week. The fun topic that everybody loves of build automation. But it is important. And when it goes wrong, it goes wrong. Yeah, I mean, I think many people who watch a show are still you know in college or in high school and so I think that it's hard one person was in elementary really no I don't know okay I made that up I was impressed so they uh
是的，完全正确，完全正确。好吧，这就是我这周要说的。每个人都喜欢的构建自动化的有趣话题。但它很重要。当它出错时，它就真的出错了。是的，我的意思是，我认为许多看节目的人仍然，你知道，在大学或高中，所以我认为很难，有一个人甚至在小学，真的，不，我不知道，好的，我是编出来的，我印象深刻，所以他们，嗯
you know it's hard to sort of appreciate this you know build system and build automation because a lot of times you're working solo but But you quickly find when you work with a team, things as what Patrick mentioned were, I had something recently where I was using a different version of Java than somebody else. And so my code work on my machine didn't work on theirs. And so these kind of problems are just multiplied when you use make files.
你知道，很难欣赏这个，你知道，构建系统和构建自动化，因为很多时候你是独自工作，但当你与团队合作时，你会很快发现，正如 Patrick 所提到的，我最近遇到了一些事情，我使用的 Java 版本与别人不同。所以我的代码在我的机器上工作，但在他们的机器上不工作。所以当你使用 makefile 时，这些问题只会成倍增加。
Oh, go ahead. I was going to say, too, the earlier you start learning to use these tools, even if you are a solo team, even if it's overhead you don't really need, but especially if you are not yet working in the industry of software, software industry. Wow, I said that poorly. As long as if you're not yet there and you say, well, why
哦，请继续。我也想说，你越早开始学习使用这些工具，即使你是一个单人团队，即使它是你并不真正需要的开销，但特别是如果你还没有在软件行业工作，软件行业。哇，我说得太差了。只要如果你还没到那里，你说，好吧，为什么
do I care? I don't work on a big team. I work by myself. Yeah, yeah, but if you learn these things now, when you go to work, it's going to be, people are going to think you're that much more genius when you show up. You get through the interview, that you show up and they're like,
我关心这个？我不为大团队工作。我一个人工作。是的，是的，但如果你现在学习这些东西，当你去工作时，人们会认为你更天才，当你出现时。你通过了面试，你出现时，他们就像，
oh, we have this thing people don't know about. It's called continuous integration. You're like, oh, no, I used that on my, you'll know about it, even if it's not the same form, even if it's not, I mean, the ideas will be there and you'll be that much more productive that much sooner.
哦，我们有这个人们不知道的东西。它叫持续集成。你就像，哦，不，我在我的上面用过那个，你会知道它的，即使它不是相同的形式，即使它不是，我的意思是，想法会在那里，你会更早地提高生产力。
And one thing I've noticed from looking at old code is even if you're working by yourself, if you go back and look at code you wrote, say, two years ago, it might as well have been written by a different person. So with that in mind, think of yourself as like a collaboration with your other selves over time. With your future self. Yeah, exactly.
而且我从看旧代码中注意到的一件事是，即使你是独自工作，如果你回去看你写的代码，比如，两年前，它可能就像是另一个人写的。所以考虑到这一点，把自己想象成随着时间的推移与你的其他自我合作。与你未来的自我。是的，完全正确。
And so writing makefiles is a way to sort of immortalize your code and hopefully keep it so that it builds a couple years from now. Well, sorry for the slight delay in the episode. We had some Skype issues last weekend, so we're recording this again. But hopefully this is a great episode. Hopefully you guys will enjoy. Yeah. Thank you again for all the reviews still coming in and the emails we get.
所以编写 makefile 是一种让你的代码永垂不朽的方法，并希望保持它，以便几年后它仍然可以构建。好吧，抱歉这一集稍微延迟了。我们上周末遇到了一些 Skype 问题，所以我们再次录制了这个。但希望这是一集很棒的节目。希望你们会喜欢。是的。再次感谢所有仍然进来的评论和我们收到的电子邮件。
Yeah, totally. And like care for you guys and gals. Yeah, yeah. If you guys have any questions about programming throwdown or anything, don't hesitate to throw a comment on our G+. Throw it down. Throw it down. Tell us what your favorite build automation tool is.
是的，完全正确。就像关心你们一样。是的，是的。如果你们对编程 Throwdown 或任何事情有任何疑问，请随时在我们的 G+ 上发表评论。扔掉它。扔掉它。告诉我们你最喜欢的构建自动化工具是什么。
Yeah, suggest languages. JMake. Brownie points for all the JMakes. I'm going to look that up. No, it might actually be a real thing. It probably is. It might be a real thing. It is a real thing.
是的，建议语言。JMake。所有 JMake 的加分项。我要去查一下。不，它可能真的是一个真实的东西。它可能就是。它可能是一个真实的东西。它是一个真实的东西。
Of course it is. Java programmers compiling large projects. All right. Okay. So I think that's all we got. So that's a wrap. Yeah. Have a good one, guys.
当然是。Java 程序员编译大型项目。好的。好的。所以我认为这就是我们所有的内容。所以这就是结束。是的。祝你们过得愉快，伙计们。
The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。